three 2
one well good morning everybody and
welcome to the development control B
meeting today 5th of August my name is
Kathy Guthrie and I'm the chairman today
may I first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are muted when you are not
speaking that you do not interrupt the
other speaker members are reminded not
to use the messaging chat function
during the meeting unless it is to
report a pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interest or that you wish to notify the
chair that you wish to make a
proposal members are reminded they
should not have alternative
communication lines open Skype and and
chats and that if you are contacted by a
third party during an application you
should bring this to the legal advisor's
attention that if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to
leave Additionally you will be invited
to speak and ask questions by the chair
of the meeting myself and we will be
using a to z so please wait your turn we
will not be using the hands up function
except for Declarations of Interest site
visit requests and Declarations of
lobbying if you're experiencing poor
connection issues in the first instance
please turn off your camera if this does
not work please turn off all incoming
video these options are under the three
dots in main information
bar I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential exempt
items if you make representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to be
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training
purposes the council members of the
public and press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully
excluded I'll now do the introductions
of course there myself Kathy Guthrie
chairman Ian D pre legal advisor Robert
carmichel governance officer John pman G
area planning manager Brun Curtis case
officer Daniel Cameron case officer and
the ward members Sarah man councelor
Sarah Manel councelor Helen geek
councelor Susie moley and councelor
Daniel
Pratt may I now move to the agenda
apologies for absence and
substitutions thank you chair I'll just
do a roll call for all members that are
in attendance today so if you could
please respond with good morning or
present councelor James carsten present
councelor Peter gold present councelor
Guthrie present counc Barry
Humphries councel Andrew
melon present councelor Mike Norris
present councelor Andrew Stringer
present Council War boys present and
I'll just go on to the ward members
chair so we have councilor
cell present councelor geek present
councelor Moy is indicated she'll join
us when the item is being heard and I
believe counc am oh
sorry apologies I thought you must
joining later but that's absolutely fine
and councelor
Pratt good morning so we are all present
chair
excellent can I have any Declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interests by
members please are there any to declare
and please use the hands up
function
right Declarations of
lobbying
no Declarations of personal site
[Applause]
visits
no confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 8th of
July are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
please no can I have a proposer and a
seconder councelor
humph
and councelor Casten so proposed and
seconded governance officer can you take
a roll call
please thank you chair if you could
please respond with for against or
abstain so councelor James carsten
four councelor Peter gold four councelor
Kathy Guri
four councel Barry Humphries
four councelor Andrew melum
four councelor Mike Norris
four councel Andrew Stringer four and
councel Roland War boys four thank you
chair that is
carried thank you to receive I will sign
that at the next practicable
opportunity to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none receed
chair now the schedule of planning
applications uh will be in the order in
which they are in the papers but I would
just like to declare that uh from
personal reasons I will be stepping
aside for the ston and Barnes issue the
second application and councelor humph
will be taking the chair on that one but
at the moment we are just going to run
in the order so we have the first one
which is land to the west of the former
bacon Factory elmswell and I'll now
invite the case officer Daniel Cameron
to introduce the application to the
committee but also Daniel can you just
allude to the late papers which we
received in 132 Pages which in fact it
was the latter part of the um of of the
uh brief that that uh was for the late
papers and if you could just mention the
Salient points on those for us please um
but can everyone turn off their videos
please um and only put the video back on
when you asked to speak thank
you uh thank you chair yeah if I run
through late papers first and then we'll
launch into um presentation on this one
so there were two parts I wanted to draw
attention to uh members um if we go to
the first that was the recovered
Secretary of State appeal at long mford
um now obviously it's a it's a baba
District Council um appeal
but I particularly wanted to draw
attention to paragraphs 52 and 53 of the
Secretary of State's letter um and in
particularly just to highlight um some
of the similarities between the two
applications um in that both fall
outside the established settlement
boundary um both Identify some visual
harm to landscape um in so far as you
would be fundamentally changing the
character of the sites um through
bringing on development um but but in
particular in those paragraphs um it was
the weight that the Secretary of State
gives to the provision of new dwellings
and in particular the provision of new
dwellings along with affordable
dwellings um that
is that significant weight is given even
in light of the 5-year housing land
Supply that can be demonstrated by Baya
District
Council um the second item I wanted to
bring to attention through the late
papers was um on page 92 of the suff
County Council cycle strategy investment
plan um this was brought before midic
District Council in Late
July um where it was um resolved to
support the County Council in bringing
forward their cycling strategy and the
plans um on page 92 we have a a plan for
a cycle link footway link to connect
elmswell and wpit um that was that was
the extent of the um of the late papers
okay thank you for that thank
you okay bear with me I'll try
and share the PowerPoint let's
see here we go can everybody see the uh
presentation yes yes I can okay thank
you chair
um so yes this is an application in
elmswell on land to the west of the
former bacon Factory site um the
application's made an outline for the
erection of up to 65 residential
dwellings 22 of which are to be
affordable um along with the outline
we're also considering access um but the
appearance layout landscaping and scale
of the site would still have to be
considered under a separate application
collectively known as Reserve
matters so we move on we have the site
location plan um some members may be
familiar with the site it has been
provided um before members on a on a
previous occasion when it was dc1 1903
924 um the red line area is the same and
we can see that there's some land in the
ownership of the applicant to the
north um if we look towards the
constraints um the only rint we have our
the public right of way that runs along
the south of the site along the railway
line and we also have the grade two
listed building some um 200 m to the
West um the site's entirely housed
within flood zone one at lowest risk of
um flood risk and it's not falling
within a conservation area and nor is it
part of a special landscape
designation if we go aerially we can see
that our aerial map stay back sometime
and you can still see the former
grampion bacon Factory on the site to
the
East and then if we go to a more recent
updated map we can see the beginnings of
the uh Taylor wimpy scheme um granted
consent under
84613 um and that proposes 190 homes on
that
site so um we have before is an
illustrative master plan um um showing
the two access points through the Taylor
wimpy
scheme we have uh an attenuation Suds
area to the north of the scheme and you
can see on the orange wrapping round um
through the middle of the scheme Parcels
of land set aside for the proposed
relief
road which also joins up to pass of land
on the adjacent Taylor wimpy site for
the relief Road as well as lining up
with the access over in the East that
provides the access point through
and we just have the two access points
in more detail here so we just have a
continuation of the estate style layout
entering this
site if we look towards the uh draft
joint local plan we have a number of
development sites proposed to come
forward within elmswell um partly in
recognition of its um status as a key
service center within um the current
plan and moving forward um within the
infrastructure development plan that
supports the joint local plan we have a
scheme for the provision of school
places within elmswell and woolpit um
combined um that consists of expansion
of the existing Primary School to a 420
Place uh maximum and the provision of a
new primary school for 420 places in
woolpit which is to be brought forward
as part of allocations in wpit if we
jump ahead we can see the the wpit um
joint local plan extract um that school
is to be formed as part of
l095 um as a key service center we have
a number of facilities located within
arswell within easy reach of the site um
including Pharmacy post office Library
preschool Primary School train station
and convenience
shops and we also on the pink line have
the intended rout for the footway cycle
way to link between elmswell and wpit um
starting at the corner of School Road
and taking in the junction of Church
Road and school road before crossing the
uh A14 on the roundabouts and coming
down Heath Road into woolpit if we
remember that site just to the west of
the Terminus of the pink line will be
the one that brings forward the new
Primary School proposed in
wpit um within the application we do
have some some um concern from highways
about the capacity of the School Road
Church Road Junction within
elmswell um this is acknowledged by the
highways Authority but in discussions
with the highways Authority a number of
alternative routes in order to reach
either woolpit or the A4 have been
discussed um those are outlined in the
solid lines both the blue and the red um
we have the dashed Blue Line showing the
the the most popular route due to speed
and convenience um but we can see that
the alternative Roots add at most a
minute and a half um and a small
increase
over the preferred
routs we also have the uh alternative
rootes to reach the
A14 um both coming down and then
following the back roads um to the next
Junction down with regards to um the
dashed line being the preferred route
obviously we're looking at maybe a
similar length Journey or a slightly
longer Journey but um not considerably
so um and moreover we're looking at
about equal lengths of
Journeys um if we look at the access to
the Taylor wimpy development because
obviously if we have the 190 on this
side plus the 65 Beyond or we'll exit
out onto the highway at this point um
now within the site themselves the
estate roads Loop Round on each other so
no issue in terms of fire safety um but
we would have um a number of units
exiting onto the main Highway at this
point in terms of um highways
issues we don't have um an objection
from the highways Authority with regards
to the number of dwellings that would be
using this access point um in part
because the access itself is slightly
over engineered with a view to the
relief road coming off which we can see
in this plan um if we look here um to
the West we have a proposed gated field
access at the moment um at some point
there is a proposed relief Road um to be
brought forward through the Elwell
neighborhood plan that would look to
link up with the land already
safeguarded Elsewhere on the Taylor
wimpy site and the land to be brought
forward within this site as well um this
plan from the Taylor wimpy application
shows it we've got the land retained for
the link road to the north there
and then in the illustrative master plan
just next to the previous plan we can
see that there's a continuation of that
for the Link Road as well now previously
when we were considering the
application there were issues regarding
infrastructure in coming back to the
infrastructure element of the of the
scheme
um correspondence with um key
infrastructure providers the NHS chess
um sub County Council as the education
Authority and the highways Authority as
well as our own planning policy team um
show that progress has been made with
regards to the delivery of
infrastructure within Elwell and wpit um
the NHS content with um a contribution
from s in order to expand the wpit
health
center education a content with a a
mixed approach between section 106 and
sill to expand facilities and to provide
um transport cost costs to provide
additional space at secondary
schools
um and highways um are content with both
the impacts of the highway on the
highway Network and also content the
cycle link um proposed between the two
would provide additional um support to
those making the journey between um the
elmswell site and the education sites in
W in wpit um considered in in in in in
regard to the the social economic and
environmental um impacts of the site and
bearing in mind significant weight given
to the delivery of housing within the
lawn mord
appeal can I just stop have I am I the
only one that's got a black screen or oh
yeah I've reached the end of the um
presentation I'm going to go back
through and um come back for you perhaps
it might be helpful to put up a plan or
something so people yes sorry to
interrupt if you no that's okay last
sentence again so people are aware of
what you're telling
us let's go back to the illustrative
master
plan that's not too far away there we go
so yeah so in terms of the
infrastructure delivery to support the
site um progress has been made with
regards to to that delivery um the NHS
is content with um Healthcare um the
education Authority content with the
approach brought forward in the
infrastructure delivery plan um to meet
future growth within elmswell and wpit
collectively um highways are content
with um both the impact of the
additional cars on the highways Network
as well as a single access point onto
the rest of the highways Network um and
further the cycle link project is
further
Advanced such that members can have some
certainty that it will be delivered
which would then create a sustainable
walking or cycling route between
elmswell and wo pit in order to allow
people to reach um facilities and either
um particularly the education facilities
but also the health
center um in coming to A A planning
balance for members um and bearing in
mind the sort of the various social
economic and environmental um ways to be
applied to the application and in in
turn bearing in mind significant weight
afforded to delivery of housing within
the um long mford appeal it's considered
that given that the um infrastructure um
demands of the site can be met um
there's
no reason for for the application to be
um or the recommendation to members
sorry is that the application is
approved um subject to conditions and
subject to securing of a section 106
agreement thank you for that
um now we need to just run through to
see if there questions from the members
please uh for the planning officer no
I'm sorry councelor Stringer we're not
using the hands up function could you
put your hand down please um questions
from Members so we'll go in order this
order we'll go for councelor warboys
first
please okay thank you um yeah well uh a
few questions one first of all while
we're looking at the illustrative master
plan
yeah uh I think you mentioned that the
land to the north of the
um the red um area which is outline blue
that's also in the owned by Taylor
[Applause]
wimpy it's not owned by Taylor wimpy
it's owned by the original landowner so
um as I understand it the original
application was brought forward by
Taylor wimpy
um having an option in in some of their
land um the red area is the area for for
consideration at present and the blue
area to the north is in the same
ownership as the current applicant okay
that thank you just a little conf uh the
the second one was um the alternative
Roots
um uh I I I am sort of I haven't visited
this site but I I do go to ell
occasionally to visit a friend there
and I'm familiar with this Junction at
school Road Church
Road um it is quite a difficult Junction
it's just opposite um can we just have a
question please councelor a coop yes I I
just wonder how do you calculate the
times for these Journeys do you
actually um do the journey or do you
actually just look at the map and think
well these are the speeds we could
expect on these sorts of roads that
might be a question can we just question
these are for clarity these are not for
debating if you don't
mindi camon yeah I wonder if um Sam
might be able to answer that one or if
Daniel feels comfortable to do so could
you choose between the two of you so I'm
I'm I'm happy to to answer so um well
I'll try and provide my lay person's
response and I'll let Sam give the
considered Engineers response um
so the times are based on an average of
Journey times at Peak time so we have
the am peak time and we have the PM peak
time um so they're based on a number of
Journeys through that time and then
we've taken the average so some days it
might be longer depending on you know if
you're coming down School Road looking
to turn on the Church Road how many cars
you see before you turn right at that
Junction and you might then take the
idea well I'll carry on the uh the other
way and avoid that Junction Al together
and get onto Church Road at another more
suable
Junction okay thank you and I've got Sam
do you have anything to
add no chair thank you um Daniels
actually said that quite right thank you
thank you very much any further
questions can can can we ask you
councelor one final very brief one in
this uh there's a letter from Taylor
wimp solicitor which um talks about
which qu questions whether he's being
double charged for supporting the school
travel plan and the school development
has that been resolved answered that's
not a planning issue is
it um I thought
it Daniel can you answer that I don't
that's a planning issue is it so in
terms of the previous application we
currently have uh an appeal before us
although it's yet to be given a start
date by the inspectorate so that cell
opinion is is provided to the applicants
and is provided in support of their um
application and I think it's useful for
members to to see to to gain an idea of
of
um the position the the applicants
intend to take it appeal now in terms of
this application in my um discussions
with the applicant they are more than
happy to sign up to section
106 for the contributions outlined by
suff County Council um and our other
infrastructure Partners so that we would
see a section 106 signed that would
deliver everything that's being asked
for at this
[Music]
moment thank you for that okay thank you
thank you councelor War boys councelor
Stringer and if you have questions yes I
do please yes I do chair thank you thank
you uh just a couple uh in the uh much
heralded appeal decision on paragraph 52
I think you you no paragraph 53 it
clearly states that there was an
identified need for the housing that was
unmet somewhere else what what
identified need for these houses do we
have in
elmswell um you also mentioned that this
that you can walk to facilities such as
health and schools Etc by accessing
School Road how do you access on foot
School Road from this site can you show
me the route Because unless you're
crossing a railway line I think the
route is yeah let them show you the
route we don't need the full debate of
what the problem is we just want the
question answered Daniel can you do that
for councelor strength
please um okay okay I I'll do that and
then we'll come back because I feel
you've got another question counc I yeah
yeah yeah we're getting into sort of a
lot all at once
okay so in terms of the route of course
you're right you'd have to go through
the Taylor wimpy site so the route if
you were probably going on foot would be
the blue dotted line that we can see
present here um if we go
back that of course links up with the
proposed footway Cycle Way route um
through to wpit as
well now in terms of identified needs um
we have got a fiveyear housing land
Supply in mids
suffk although I think that paragraph in
in the in the report also notes and that
is can't be seen to be a ceiling on on
development it needs to be
um is a basemark for us to reach so we
do have applications coming forward we
do have allocations coming forward in
the joint local
plan and I believe that the local need
and um other information in the long
mford case was supplied at appeal by the
applicants so so so just I think you've
got your answer councelor Stringer but
if you ask your next question I don't
feel I have but well well I I'm sort of
with you on that but I think we can do
it in debate when you know when you
bring that up in debate that would be
useful I think your third question if
you um okay well okay I prefer to have
the information before I debate anyway
um the alternative Roots um I'm I'm
completely mystified uh in in terms of
is The Junction at School Road and
Church Road at capacity or overc
capacity and is heavily congested if
so how would someone leaving this site
in a car know that they should take the
alternative route and that the junction
snagged up and and congested I I don't
understand given that most drivers every
driver normally measures a journey in
time and they normally take the shortest
route in time and every satnav does that
so I I I don't quite understand just
because an alternative Road exists how
will drivers take the alternative route
and know they
should so I think in terms of drivers
knowing to take alternative routes I
think part of it is
um you know probably speaking from my
experience getting to work there are
certain routes I will go there are
certain routes I will try and avoid but
that come comes from an element of
experience um I think as well there's
also an element of um looking at the
other traffic on the road and making a
judgment call based on where you might
see them go now we do have an
application at school Road that's
looking to bring forward some Junction
Improvement but at present um as I
understand it within the TA and maybe
Sam Harvey can jump in and correct me if
I'm wrong at present The Junction is
busy but it's not at capacity it comes
to capacity with the other plan
developments coming forward within
elmswell is that correct
Sam yes that's correct with the commited
developments and proposed and this
proposed development in the year 2024
it's at capacity just over actually can
we just have Clarity on that is that
including this application or before
this
application it's it's including so it's
the committed development that's um been
put forward and has been given
permission this proposed development
growth and also the year
2024 does that help councelor
Stringer yeah yes so so so so that
answer doesn't include what's already
coming up in that doesn't include their
neighborhood plan and Joint local plan
allocations may I come in on that yeah
please
do so in terms of the uh neighborhood
plan that is at a very early stage um
and is not uh is of limited weight at
this current time um I believe it's just
out as a draft I don't think it's got
any further than that it's only at stage
two in terms of our emerging local plan
uh Daniel just mentioned the uh School
Road allocation that allocation is for
50 that is on the the corner of uh the
School Road uh just to the south of
elmswell Hall uh itself um but on this
side on the south side of the Railway
track that allocation has already
foreseen the traffic uh issues and
within that allocation there is Junction
improvements required of that allocation
to School Road and uh Church Road so you
know the local plan in terms of its
allocations has already taken into
account the accumulative uh Junction
improvements necessary or needing to be
explored as part of that process um but
ultimately it is recognized that there
will be a point where we get to
capacity uh and um you know once the
hopefully the emerging local plan is on
board that will come forward uh on on
that basis um in the meantime we are not
yet uh at the and we we admit we're
quite close but we're not yet at that
point uh where we've exceeded official
capacity does that help right I think
that's helpful and I think um with
respect to your good self counselor
Stringer if we can bring that up further
in the debate um because I'm sure a lot
of people have something to say on that
so we've got that um in our uh Armory to
for discussion if that's all right with
you can we move on to councelor Norris
if he has any questions
please I thank you um not really a
question as such it's well I only need
questions at this time coun Norris I
just going to explain really some points
regarding planning and no no no I don't
want
explanations sorry sorry a point of
policy that you don't understand is that
it sorry sorry questionis these are
questions what is the question no the
questions relate it's more for the
debate I'm saying then can we hang on
for the debate these are comments more
for the debate rather than the question
so I will Reserve wait until the debate
then that's right thank you very much
indeed councelor melon do you have a
question uh yes thank you chair I've got
a couple of questions um the first one
is um uh the officer in his presentation
um made the comment that the cycling and
walking link to wpit from
elmswell um has been progressed I think
that was the word he used or has been
taken further forward can we just unpack
that a bit and see um or perhaps have a
bit more information on how far it's
progressed how it's progressed um what's
the likelihood and timing of its
construction so in terms of timings I
might have to defer to colleagues from
highways but in terms of the footway
cycle way link um it utilizes a it will
utilize a combination of susr land and
um land coming forward um from allocated
development through 278 Works to to
bring to fruition um and we'd also see a
contribution from this application um
towards it um in terms of bringing it
forward it was part of the
um sub County Council cycle strategy
investment plan um which was discussed
by mids Council and resolved to support
um and is shown on page 992 I think the
fact that the majority of that table is
blank I think does illustrate the fact
that although
the the route is proposed and um work is
going forward to deliver it um there are
probably some question marks about how
quickly it can be delivered um although
probably that is a case for how quickly
development sites come forward um
following adoption of the The Joint
local plan as well um I'll hand over to
Sam Harvey and and she might be able to
fill in a little bit a little bit more
information for you
counselor yes thank you Daniel um the
applications that have come forward that
we've secured some money through section
106 uh at at present uh we have monies
available we have enough money to start
the
design for but I'm un able to give you a
time for when construction would be
because again it depends on funding and
it depends on design at the moment there
isn't a trigger given for any of the
developments putting funding funding
into here as in before occupation or on
the 50th occupation ET
Etc so I'm able to give you
timings okay thank you for that
councilor melon do you have a further
question uh yeah one more thank you
chair um in the uh papers we received
the there was um the the legal opinion
which the previous
application um had received on their
appeal can I just ask is that a material
consideration it's not a material
consideration to this application but is
to make members aware of the the appeal
rumbling on in the background um and the
approach likely be taken by the
applicant at the appeal um in terms of
um material weight no it's it's it's not
Material we should considering this
application that is before as on its own
merits okay thank you no further
question thank you for that councelor
melon councelor Humphrey's any
questions no questions thank you madam
chair thank you councelor gold any
questions no my my questions have
already been asked and answered thank
you thank you very much and I I did make
one
I think you answered my question that I
had noted up to so we're all right on
that one thank you very much so we now
move on um to public speakers and I will
I beg your pardon um Madame chairman oh
I'm sorry councelor Casten I do beg your
pardon do you have a question I beg your
pardon you're on the next yes
please um question regarding the um
Secondary School places um provision um
does the infrastructure delivery plan
deal with this um need we have from this
particular development for secondary
school places and is it physically able
to expand using that the 272,000 that is
provided it's my understanding that it
is yes um the education Authority don't
tend to um well if the school isn't
capable of being expanded there would be
a need for a section 106 contribution in
in order to provide a new facility um
given that they've asked for sale in
this instance um there should be
sufficient place at the site to expand
um it will likely also expand as a
result of um the other um applications
and sites coming forward in elmswell um
through um current applications and and
the joint local
plan okay thank you thanks very much
apologies about that um so we now are
the parish council representative Peter
da and you have three minutes to address
um the committee if you would please and
Robert will tell us the three minutes
and I believe on screen it will mark it
down is that correct
Robert S twice um the uh so we won have
a mark bit if I um I will let Mr D know
when there's 30 seconds if that's
acceptable than would be helpful Mr da
good morning good morning chair thank
you for having me uh you can hear me
indeed very clear elmsville Paris
council's position is clearly and
frequently stated and the village was
much relieved at the control committee
decision in February of this year to
refuse exactly this
application councilors and the public
took this to be a pivotal moment when
another of plan opportunistic planning
application was assessed at length by
members and offices and found to be a
step too far in the gradual drip drip
erosion of our quality of life in it
would overload key infrastructure
elephant elephants elephants can go uh
particularly highways as have been
suggested by members this fanciful
suggestion of alternative access routes
all of which use the same Junction uh
and to answer councelor warboys I think
it was the queue is estimated at the
school Road application to be 18 cars at
a time members may be aware of the
uplifting spirits in the neighboring
Siege Villages of thirst and woith Etc
at the thought that there really is a
line to be drawn in the sand Elm Paris
Council on behalf of its Community urges
members to stick to their original
resolve in drawing that
line we ask that you resist the honeyed
words of the applicant advisers who Trot
out the mantras of sustainable
development Etc encouraging the idea
that another 65 houses will add to elm's
vitality and who suggests there is Merit
in the ongoing appeal the tactics being
used here of parallel applications
during the appeal process amount to a
form of blackmail the applicant does not
hide this uh members are offered a
second chance with the inescapable
implication that it is an offer they
can't refuse please do exactly that
nothing has changed the decision to say
that this is an application too far
should stand and elmswell urges members
to to stick to their guns and to refuse
again thank you for that now do we have
any questions for the parish council
councilor War
boys no no no no questions thank you
thank you councelor
Stringer yes I do chair um the uh
officer said uh regarding the or local
plan neighborhood plan that it was at an
early
stage but he then went on to say that
you were approaching draft stage I've
been through a neighborhood plan process
draft stage is not an early stage U Can
Stringer can you ask a question or um we
will debate that
point I I will ask a question but I
don't want to speak over you so what
what we've what what I was asking was
you know at what stage actually are you
at have you done a load of uh surveys
meetings with the public and and paid
Consultants work
etc yes we've done all of those things
largely because we've been doing this
for the last seven years uh it is very
well Advanced but not yet Advanced
enough to be put on paper and called a
plan largely because of issues which are
reiterated here regarding the relief
Road the cycle path Etc all of which are
very much up in the air and which very
much muddy the Waters we are within 3
weeks of presenting two officers uh at
mids suffk a raw draft for their first
opinion thank you councelor Stringer any
further
questions no that's it thank you chair
than thank you councelor Stringer
councelor
Norris sorry no questions thank you
melan uh no questions chair councelor
Humphries no questions chair thankk you
councelor gold no questions thank you
thank you councelor Casten no questions
thank you and I don't have a question um
so thank you for that um we don't have
an objector or supporter so I will now
ask the agent Matt Gilbert to speak and
you have three minutes to address the
committee
please good morning everybody and thank
you chair for giving me the opportunity
to make a few brief comments um
Daniel Cameron of course has already
referred you to the uh previous proposal
on this site as has Mr da on behalf of
arish council and I should say that in
submitting this application we have
generally proceeded on the principles
that whilst we are aware there are other
concerns and particularly in relation to
highways which Mr DA has just referred
to they did not justify refusal last
time around and they were accepted um by
your committee and I hope that still is
the case and so therefore that really
leaves us with the uh concerns that were
set out within the uh previous refusal
that related to infrastructure and
particularly uh to regarding School
places now our application has given a
great deal of thought to those matters
which is all set out in the submitted uh
papers and you will also have seen that
they've been addressed in detail in the
officer's report that you have before
you today and Mr Mr Cameron has uh uh in
in introducing this application gone
through those various infrastructure
issues and with the advice and support
of the County Council has concluded that
all of the infrastructure issues can be
addressed through the sill and section
payments National guidance of course
makes clear that where such matters can
be addressed by these means planning
permission should not be
refused now with respect to the specific
issue of school places the education
Authority confirmed that their plans for
school provision for both elmswell and
woolpit will be met through either a new
school or or an expanded School located
in wpit and it's confirmed furthermore
that there will be space to accommodate
pupils from this development as well as
those from other planned and committed
proposals this approach is recognized in
your infrastructure delivery plan and is
now supported by your planning policy
officers as well therefore I hope you
can see why your officers and the County
Council both advised that this is a
matter for a financial contribution and
not a reason why planning permission
should be
refused we support the conclusions in
your office's report and uh I take from
that report the facts that this proposal
is highly sustainable it will support
local Services it will provide 22
affordable dwellings and deliver
significant social and economic benefits
and of course there are no
infrastructural reasons why the
development should not be permitted and
it's for those reasons chair that I
encourage members to approve this this
application proposal thank
you thank you for that um may we have
questions uh for the agent councelor
warboys anything from you
please yes I I do um in the refute
reasons for refusal of planning
application as well as the impact on the
infrastructure there was also a comment
at the end of it about the local
planning Authority attempting to discuss
its concerns with the applicant it was
not able to secure the necessary
improvements to the scheme that would
have enabled the proposal to be
considered more favorably has has the
developer now been uh discussing this
proposal with the local planning
Authority uh well throughout the course
of this application the answer to that
is yes that we've been in touch with Mr
Cameron uh and trying to answer any
queries that he he may have had or
indeed other consules have had during
that process and of course the the
culmination of that uh dis process of
discussion is that you have before you a
recommendation that the application be
approved so um in in my mind at least I
think that we can't go much further than
getting that recommendation before you
today there's nothing outstanding there
that uh we have not provided that we
have been asked for for
example okay thank you you councelor
Stringer a question for the agent please
yeah yes I do thank you chair uh you you
referred to the site being highly
sustainable is there any issues with
this site uh up and above any other site
like ground conditions that would cause
any extra uh Works to be carried
out I'm not aware of anything
significant with the site there there is
there is some uh residue of its past use
I understand that has to be dealt with
and of course as with any development
site there would be a cost associated
with doing that but as in general terms
there is no significant issue that in
any way questions the the ability to
bring the development
forwards thank you any further question
counc Stringer uh no thank you chair
thank thanks councelor Stringer
councelor Norris uh no questions thank
you councelor
melon uh yes thank you chair
um um the officer Daniel Cameron has
said that you're happy to pay the um
section 106 and S monies that would uh
be charged from this development is that
correct we we we've uh written to Mr
Cameron uh to confirm in relation to
this application that we will make those
contributions if if you resolve to Grant
planning
permission okay can I then ask why
you've sought a legal opinion uh a
detailed legal opinion on challenging
these
amounts that that was something that we
uh we took in relation to the uh the
previous application that of course uh
you know is is the subject of an appeal
um what we have made clear is that we do
um with the greatest of respect have
queries in relation to a number of those
uh requested payments so far as in terms
of their justification as it were um and
so therefore you know if if the if the
matter went to appeal they would be
arguments that we would put to the
appeal inspector um but so far as this
application is concerned we've taken
what I think I described in the email as
a pragmatic approach and said look we
will make those payments in relation to
to this particular proposal that's
without prejudice to the position we
have in relation to uh the appeal
proposal where we ever to get to that
point I hope we
won't okay I can't quite understand
whether you're happy to it's questions
it's not whether you're understanding it
we'll debate it ourselves thank you no
further questions councelor
humph no questions thank you madam chair
councelor gold no questions thank you
councelor Casten no questions thank you
and myself no I think we'll just leave
it as it is for debate um and so thank
you very much indeed if you'd like to um
turn off your video thank you and um I
will now ask the ward member um
councelor Manel if you would speak
please councelor Mansel thank you would
it be possible for councelor Geek to go
first I haven't got her down here sorry
I didn't know she was going of course it
would be possible absolutely counselor
geek if you would like
do thank you chair um can I just say to
begin with that I support the points
that Mr da from elel Parish Council has
made um in addition I'd like to point
out that the infrastructure issues have
still not been addressed um as the
committee papers say page 25 the current
application is materially identical to
the previous application um in in many
senses the site isn't included in the
joint local plan land allocations it's
not included in the neighborhood plan
allocations this was a factor cited by
several members in the debate and the
decision in February and there is no
difference now to the waiting that
should be given to those two plans
compared to February the settlement
boundary is not out of date there is no
local need in the village for more
housing elwell's got nearly 700 homes
already in the pipeline um par page 29
um as we've seen still talks about the
how there is a primary school within a
12-minute walk this is still completely
IR relevant the children from this site
won't be able to be accommodated at
elmswell Primary School not now and not
in the future all of this developments
primary school children will need to be
transported outside the village with
massive knock-on effects for traffic at
the uh especially at the school road and
New Road Junctions and the preschool
mentioned in this paragraph is equally
irrelevant that particular preschool is
full planning permission hasn't yet been
granted for another one now at the
moment that new Primary School envisaged
in wpit doesn't exist and the cycle and
foot path between elmswell and woolpit
doesn't yet exist we've heard about the
uncertainty over timing and funding and
the necessary agreements for both of
those have not yet been secured I think
I'm right in saying that because of this
no weight can be put on those I mean
really as you'll have noticed there's
just an awful lot of unknowns still to
be sorted out in any case the proposed
cycling and walking route between the
two Villages is hilly and difficult it
goes over the A14 on a bridge shared
with Lor's that cycle path is not a
Panacea it makes sustainable travel
between those two Villages possible but
not easy the choice in inverted commas
of which means of transport to use to
get your children to a school in woolpit
is tilted significantly in favor of the
car at present now you may say ah but
there will be a bus but in another
Village in laxfield uh the Baba midu
planning policy team commented that and
I quote if the primary school could not
expand development would cause adverse
harm in respect of Social and
environmental conditions because the
children arising from this development
would need to be Bust or driven to the
nearest primary school so if a lack of
primary school places in laxfield is
harmful surely this is also the case in
elmswell and then lastly page 28 of the
papers talks about the employment that
the construction will provide house
building is a powerful stimulus for
growth it both creates and supports many
jobs while it is going on well as I said
to you all back in February so does coal
mining we can't cover our Countryside
with more and more development just
because it creates jobs while it's being
built these houses if indeed they are
ever built will stand for a century or
more the carbon emissions caused by
their building will be around for even
longer we have to look to the future
rather than concentrating on the short
term thank
you thank you for that um do would you
like to have questions now if anybody
would like questions for you as Ward
member because obviously you want to go
don't you no I'll I'll stay until
questions after Sarah if if you want to
take questions for both of us together
I'd be fine with that I don't mind okay
councilor Manel would you like to um uh
give us your views on this please uh
thank you um I I'll try not to repeat um
what other people have already said um
but uh I would just like to reiterate
that this application is materially
identical to the application which this
committee
um determined and refused uh back in
February uh there so there's been no
change to this application but are there
any other material uh factors that we
need to which maybe have changed uh and
as far as I can see uh there has been a
committee decision which was uh later on
in February to approve the application
on the land north of Barry Road woolpit
uh which includes the site for uh
potential site for the new Primary
School uh but that has the decision
notice has yet to be issued so that is
still completely uncertain we do not
know when or if such a school will ever
materialize uh and even if it did uh as
councilor geek has said it is a
completely unsustainable solution for
Education provision for children who
live in this development or anywhere in
elmswell um and the other the other
things that I think have changed is that
we have even more uncertainty because of
coid and because of brexit um and we
don't even know if these houses are
really needed we don't know what effect
any of those are going to have on the
housing need of wpit um so in my opinion
this is still an unsustainable
development and it will put unacceptable
pressure on the existing
infrastructure uh the highways response
uh still makes the Mind Boggle um the
highways response of the 30th of June
2020 is remarkable it's on page 18 of
our committee report it says that we
don't need to worry that the traffic
model predicts cues and delays on School
Road because in reality these are
unlikely to occur apparently drivers
from this development will find an
alternative route rather than queuing
they will travel down New Road to Cross
Street Junction and turn East or West
firstly what's the point of doing
traffic modeling uh if when it gives the
wrong answer we just ignore it secondly
uh what suffer County highways don't
seem to have cottoned on to is the fact
that any route Western West Westerly
route out of elmswell and in fact it's
quite clearly shown on slide 13 that all
of those routes to the west of elmswell
go through the School Road Church Road
Junction there is no other way out of
elmswell in that direction up you have
to go through that Junction um and the
alternative route of going down um New
Road um that road hasn't got a pavement
all the way down it it's in the middle
of the V it is highly used by
pedestrians the last thing we want to do
is encourage uh traffic to be going down
down New Road um we also hear from
suffer County Council that if work
allows people will May travel outside of
the peak hours to avoid cues and delays
that's marvelous but most a lot of the
traffic created by this development will
be people driving their children to
school and school does not allow travel
outside of peak hours of the morning so
what we'll end up with is Q's
frustration and more importantly
pollution which affects drivers Walkers
cyclists and residents
alike now we've heard that there is some
opinion that the reasons for the
previous decision are not robust but
we've simil we've subsequently been told
that that is not a material
consideration um and we really won't
know what that's uh whether they are
robust or not until it's been tested so
I really don't see why um this committee
should change its mind because
effectively what I it's what I call
tantamount bullying to change the mind
their minds for this decision um there
has been no change since February and if
there has been any change it's made it
more um uh unacceptable um The Joint
local plan has no more weight than it
did in February um and in my opinion the
infrastructure delivery plan solution
for Education provision for this part of
our district is so unsustainable it
Beggars belief
uh so I would urge you to stick with
your previous decision to refuse this
application thank
you sorry I was muted uh thank you
counselor Manel and cancel geek just
before we go to questions um can I just
ask um
Daniel uh just to point out any
significant changes so that we can then
ask questions accordingly between this
and the other one could you just point
that out to make it clear for members
thank you
Daniel so in terms of the description of
the applications are both the same both
for outline um plan permission with
access to be considered for the erection
of to 65
houses um in that respect they are they
are material identical um in terms of um
the reason for refusal previously that
leans heavily on the infrastructure
provision Within Elwell and wipit um in
looking at that again with our
infrastructure partners and our planning
policy team we have found that there
isn't the same support for that reason
of refusal here hence the fact that
we've moved away from the the reason of
refusal given um previously by
committee um that said you know we are
we are looking at outline application so
there's a limit to how much information
will be provided at this
point um you know and we will get a
second application if approved to
discuss the reserve matters at which
point we can start to look into more
matters of appearance layout landscaping
and
scale right um thank you for that but um
um that was just as Council Manel you'd
brought up you know that very eloquently
so I just thought we could get that um
on the table so let's go to questions
for the Ward members and um you can ask
them jointly as it were uh Council of
War
boys uh no questions thank you councelor
Norris sorry I was muted and no
questions thank
you councelor
melon councelor melon yes sorry I was
just struggling to unmute I know they
you hit the button and then it closes
then it opens again I think you
councelor Stringer out of the list
before me but I'm happy to go first oh
is he no I've got C oh I'm going a list
here oh we've oh
sorry I I won't say it but councelor
melon you go ahead and then we'll put in
councelor Stringer yeah um yes so the
the question is um for the um the ward
members um around the the the progress
of this um neighborhood plan plan and
the work that the the the parish
council's been doing on that um would
you um what's your perception of the um
the feelings of the community about this
development is there anyone who's
positive about
it I think Sarah that's probably one for
you I don't know of anybody who is
positive about development in elmswell
um um I think the major vast majority of
the residents think that we've already
got um almost 700 houses being built in
the village uh and that is sufficient
why do we need any more I would say that
that is the sort of generic um fallback
position of most residents that I've
come across um they all get frustrated
about the um the traffic through the
Village um and about the health
provision um those are the things that
you know commonly crop up when you talk
to Residents um and I can only reiterate
what uh Peter da said about the
neighborhood plan uh we are fast
approaching uh our first sort of draft
which will be sent to the district
council uh in the next few
weeks okay thank you chair no further
questions uh councelor Stringer sorry
you weren't on my list I have to go down
my list councelor Stringer yeah thank
you chair uh my my question is Also
regarding the neighborhood plan have
have you assessed uh if there would be
any Fallout to your neighborhood plan if
this were
approved uh I'm I'm not quite sure what
you mean by Fallout um this uh
particular site uh is not likely to be
allocated in the draft neighborhood plan
it's not allocated in the joint local
plan and the neighborhood plan has been
trying to dovetail with the joint local
plan um we already have as far as the
joint local plan goes the uh existing
sites uh meet the requirements I know
there's no harm in over meeting the
requirements uh so I can't see that it's
going to cause a problem if we don't get
this one uh because we've got plenty of
other things that will be um allocated
sites is that is that really I don't
really know what what you meant by
Fallout but sorry my question was the
other way would would approving this do
any damage to your neighborhood
plan
probably not but other than the fact
that we've already got too much traffic
at the school Road Church Road Junction
uh and if we have another 65 dwellings
that aren't allocated um it's going to
make the make the situation
worse thank you councelor Stringer um is
that sufficient with your
questions ye yes chair I think so yeah
thank you uh councelor Humphries
Madam chair no questions thank you
councelor gold uh no questions thank you
councelor
Casten thank you very much Madam chair
um a um question to councilor Manel um
you described the um infrastructure
delivery plan as unsustainable you
couldn't just tell me a bit more about
why you believe that's
unsustainable I believe it is
unsustainable to educate children in one
of the largest villages in the county um
in another Village uh I resent the uh um
officers mentioning uh combining and
talking about the infrastructure
provision of elmsall and wpit
collectively elmsall and wpit are two
separate large communities and there is
uh as I see it the the plan is not being
what we call plan Le uh because if you
had a plan-led system you would make
sure that the development of housing uh
goes alongside development of education
provision within a community not outside
of a community um how uh educating
children in the next door Village can be
CED sustainable when everyone is going
to be driving their children over the A4
uh Beggars belief it is completely
unsustainable to encourage uh people to
be driving their children to primary
school thank you for that much um and I
don't have any questions for the ward
members so if we move on we now move
into the debate so I'm going in the
order that this has been given to me so
I do apologize um we will go first of
all to councelor Casten please we're
opening the debate do you have some
comments to make
please um
no sorry mute um no comment at the
debate but you'll go around again will
you yes I will indeed yeah yeah sorry I
was expecting to um be last on the list
sorry so was I but I'm just going by
what's been printed off so I don't miss
everybody but sadly I missed councelor
Stringer a minute ago apologies um
councelor gold do you have something to
say with regard to this application yeah
uh thank you very much chair for me the
question here is whether there's been uh
sufficient material changes
um so as to justify a different decision
to that that we took uh last
time and I'm having difficulty in
thinking that there are um substantive
material differences to what we saw
before excuse me excuse me Peter did you
say that are or aren I didn't hear you I
I I have difficulty seeing that there
are material differences is to last time
so it a longwinded way of making a
simple Point apologies for that no no no
I misge you thank you um a kind of an
alternative uh question is whether the
reasons the committee had for refusing
the application last time were
sufficiently robust um and there's a
challenge from the applicants uh QC in
that respect but I don't actually recall
any caution or advice from uh the
officers at the point that we were
um discussing and voting on those
reasons for refusal uh such as to make
us think that they weren't uh
sufficiently robust but I if if if the
officers have a different view on that
on what what we were advised uh I i' I'd
welcome been reminded of it um another
kind of issue is whether the long mford
pill decision which has come in since uh
we last we looked at the last
application uh is is so instructive on
this case that really we have to pay
regard to it but we are not told that in
those terms in the report it is simply
put before us in the table papers and
similarly we given the uh the the legal
opinion of of the applicants uh
Bara uh we're told it's not
Material so question why why is it there
then um and if it is there and it's
important it is saying something about
the decision that we took last time I
would have appreciated having the
benefit of some advice whether
privileged or not in relation in
relation to that opinion so that's
that's where I'm sitting at the moment
on on this application
chair uh thank you for that uh councelor
gold I think that's a very valid point I
must admit I I did mention it in our
briefing as well so perhaps either John
or um Daniel could just give us a a
little bit of a steer of councelor G's
question regarding that thank
you
thank you chairman
um how to unpack this then
ultimately this is the same application
as
before but we as officers consider the
circumstances have altered but I will
make a point that we did recommend this
for approval
previously and we're maintaining that
view in any event the
differences
long mford appeal is a significant
difference in because it defined to not
just this Authority as mids District
Council but other authorities as well
that we can't have a cap on development
just because housing need has been dealt
with as far as a 5-year housing Supply
is concerned that will not get accepted
by the Secretary of State if we go to
that point so we have to bear that in
mind that is significant in that respect
and that is a
difference we have got changes in terms
of accessibility to Services which was a
point of the refusal in this case those
changes and what weight you give to
those changes is your debate but uh does
in concern a cycle strategy that this
Council has sought to support of the
county that cycle strategy now includes
the link between War pit and elmw well
as part of that strategy we have got
contributions actively being made
towards that viable link something that
we didn't have when this application was
first dealt with
previously
um in terms of our policy
position I might ask Dan to make more
comments on that because I've not been
involved in those direct discussions
myself but we are not comfortable or
confident in respect to the position
taken about Educational Services access
and we don't have any objection from the
county on this
basis and I think that's simply it and I
can't really add much more than
that thank you for that John um one
thing um I would just say um is you
mentioned that we have contributions
towards the cycle strategy that we
didn't have before but um the applicant
has clearly said they're running a a
tandem um appeal with the inspector now
which one's going to win out um if
members are minded to approve this one
where we've got
contributions and the inspector says
well um we like the other one or the
inspector puts it through on appeal we
won't get the contributions so we're
damned if we do and damned if we don't
either way um would that be a fair point
to take into
account par unfortunately planning
planning is often about timing um at
this moment in time the appeal as I
understand it is not is no decision and
it's not yeah so um at the moment we
don't know where that Journey may take
us that is a separate Journey to the
application before us the application
before us has got Security on those
Provisions uh as set out in your papers
and Page 36 yes so what I'm saying is if
the contributions we we decide to uh
approve this one and we say yes we like
this one and then the secretary of state
says well he likes that one we lose the
contributions anyway don't we
potentially they could Implement that
appeal decision and pursue that if they
were allowed um as opposed to anything
secured under this
application right okay well um sorry to
have jumped in there um but councelor
ghoul brought up a valid point there um
we move on to councelor humph if you
would
please M chair thank you um yeah a few
points I'm going to cover some of the
stuff that's brought up in questions
didn't see the point doing it there um
there's lots of talk about what's going
on in and around or rather around the
actual development itself not so much
about development the outline plan um
the comments about not being able to
walk from that development to School
Road
um because there's a railway line there
we can still walk there there's a
crossing and people walk there every day
both sides south to North North to S so
I don't see that's an issue alternative
roots and timings there are some uh and
there's some issues with the timings and
I get the the the points about well are
those timings correct are they for each
time of the day but they're stab in the
dark but they're all alternative routes
and as with the current residents new
residents will find new routes new ways
uh they'll have favorite Roots uh at or
they'll put it with traffic jams but
again they'll they'll adapt and overcome
but that's outside of the actual
development um the neighborhood plan um
Council Stringer kept going on about the
neighborhood plan but even the counselor
from the parish said that actually it's
not an advanced stage in fact it's not
even down on paper yet uh so therefore
it's got limited weight uh right at this
moment I think that's an important point
to remember that it's got limited weight
um schooling um as has been alluded to
body offices um suff County Council
don't see anything isue with this is
still contributions and they believe
that there's enough schooling that'll be
adequate for this development and the
town of Elm Village of
elmswell councilor geek um to say
there's no housing requirement I find
that incredible there is a housing
requirement and that's definitely the
intention of the government right now
and people need housing especially
affordable housing to link it to coal
mining car carbon foot footprint I found
fible um would we say the same if we're
going to build a hospital which has the
same sort of carbon output on on on
actually developing it and building it
it brings much needed employment and
especially these postco days that is
important and so is housing um however
you look at it um there is a good mix of
housing on this development I believe
there will be as in affordable housing
and Market housing um highways have not
got a major issue and uh educational
again no major comments from uh suff
County Council due to S contributions in
my opinion there are no planning reasons
why you can turn this down but that's
just my opinion um um and it's great
that developers agree to pay the sums
that he's been asked to pay um yeah
councilor Manel she expressed her own
opinion on the infrastructure delivery
pan but the officers uh have already
stated that actually uh it actually
delivers everything it's meant to
deliver in the right way there a
personal opinion on that and there is a
cycle Lane to wpit we keep going on
about vehicles and the fact people will
have to drive to woolpit to school would
we have the same argument if in 10 years
time everybody that drove had an
electric car they'll be using cars just
a different type which have a low carbon
output so therefore I don't see the
issue people do drive to school they'll
continue to drive school but there is an
option of Walkin and there is an option
option of a cycle Lane which is going to
be further developed um I looked at like
councelor G what's the difference
between this application and a previous
application on refusal um and it's on
1210 on page 35 the previous reason for
refusal concerning in the impacts on
infrastructure two Villages is noted but
is addressed by the content of the
emerging joint local plan and the
infrastructure delivery plan
irrespective of your own personal
comments on that which addresses
education infrastructure in both
elmswell and wpit through the
development of a new Primary School in
wpit and expansion of the existing
School in elmswell consultation with
subit County Council confirms that
sufficient capaity available within the
facilities to accommodate both the plan
level of growth in elmswell and wpit but
also that of when for development such
as application uh therefore our previous
reason for refusal was pretty much based
on that and yet seems to be addressed so
um at the moment I'm finding it hard to
find a planning reason why you'd refuse
this thank you thank you for that
councelor
Humphries we come to councelor melon
please um thank you chair um I just need
to say right at the start that I wasn't
on the the planning committee um when
this decision uh the previous decision
was determined um and as a you know a
very Junior member of the committee and
and a relatively new counselor um I find
this a strange situation and I don't
like the situation we're in where we
have a second application before us
identical to the first and yet there's a
and also an appeal running it it feels
strange it feels wrong um and um there
can I just advise you on that councilor
melon this happens all the
time sorry to interrupt beg you about
thank you chair um anyway uh we are
where we are we've got to deal with this
one um I I did read the the applicant's
legal opinion on the previous
application and um and um you know was
was somewhat uh overed by that but I was
glad to hear that is not actually
material con consideration in this case
so the weight we have to put uh on the
changes that have happened since the
last time this decision was made that
that seems to be the critical thing um
and there aren't many changes the only
thing that seems to have changed is that
the the potential walking and cycling
link has has got a step
forward um minor step forward on the
process um it's no nowhere near being
delivered
um the the the developments around
woolpit and
elmswell
um there's there's a lot going on there
there's a kind of Nexus of development
around those two Villages which um is
concerning for residents it's concerning
for um the the ward members MERS as
Community
representatives and um we can start to
see already I think the cumulative
effects uh in terms of increased you
know traffic increased
congestion um and we know that there's a
lot more to come in terms of the
allocated sites from the
jlp which are not even you know shovel
ready yet so um this one is is sort of
there when there's there's still others
we know are definitely going to come um
and I have a struggle with it because I
um I can see the cumulative effects when
I drive through elmswell
already um you know it may be in 10
years time that we're all driving
electric cars but you can still have a
traffic jam full of electric cars
um we need to move away from people B
being in their cars and it can be done I
mean I went to school at um in grave
where um the school there has the
highest proportion of cycle travel of
any school in Europe and that's simply
because the infrastructure is there in
place um if we could do that here it
would be great um and that would
certainly help to ameliorate the
problems there um but I'll listen to the
rest of the debate but that's where I
stand at the moment not very much not
very keen on this application and and
somewhat feeling it between a rock and a
hard
place
thank you for that counselor I think
you've put my words
into into the fall there between a rock
and a hard place it's difficult thank
you for your comments councelor Norris
please thank you madam chairman
sorry no you're fine oops I've come back
right um thanks I do have to say I still
have consider reservations concerning
the infrastructure capacity for this
development on top of what's already
been approved for elmsville uh including
on highways
matters I have concerns regarding the
comments from planning Policy Department
on page
21 in the first
paragraph The Mention Of The Proposal be
would it expand Elms further than what
is being strategically planned
for in the second paragraph they talk
about there are infrastructure
Provisions that need to be taken into
consideration as to how future
development can deliver sustainable
needs and in the third paragraph
significant material considerations from
an ecology biodiversity landscape
Heritage and setting value to the area
should be com comprehensively assessed
uh so
overall I feel I will not be able to
support this second application on this
site thank you thank you councelor
Norris and now we come to councelor
Stringer
please uh thank you chair uh we've heard
uh from others that uh there is ay
there's a cycle route in there is
education provision all all accommodated
uh but it isn't the cycle link is not
here it is a route proposed on a map
that has been roughly costed that's it
that's as far as we've got um so if
you're adding uh more to the weight of
sustainability then that that that needs
to be you know a lot further down the
road as far as I'm concerned um I also
uh just want to reiterate the point
because uh one of the council certainly
didn't understand about the walking rout
yes people walk across that Railway
Junction every day but the likelihood of
them do doing it if they live tens of
meters away from the road that allows
them to do that just to get right the
way round to a point that's probably 50
yards from where they started the
likelihood of them doing that is remote
so what they will do is jump in their
car that is the basis of sustainable
development you make the right decision
the easiest one and this proposal makes
the wrong decision the easiest and most
likely in my opinion
what I think we need to for what's
changed what has changed we've agreed a
timetable on our joint local plan which
that plan doesn't allocate this site
we've also heard we haven't seen the
neighborhood plan but the neighborhood
plan for elmsall has been years in the
making which means public consultation
where would you like your development
and the Secretary of State actually puts
a huge amount of weight behind those
consultations because it's the agreement
of the people so the people don't agree
to this because it's not proposed as
part of their noo plan it's not in our
joint local plan despite it being highly
sustainable we're told um yet this thing
about
education all the county council's doing
is taking the contribution say yeah well
actually we we we can move them to this
other facility that we haven't built yet
as the growth comes but it won't be in
in in that Village which is I agree with
the board member that's highly
unsustainable and it's not brilliant for
a community either to have to have
children busted around like that and
moved around like that uh to schools uh
we we were pushed towards looking at the
appeal inspection at long mford uh you
know and I have to say that paragraph 53
is Paramount for me it sh there that
there was an identified local need that
hadn't been fulfilled therefore it was
agreed there is an identified local need
in elmsville which is been fulfilled by
its draft neighborhood plan and it's by
our own joint local plan so as far as
I'm concerned I would be uh voting
against this and and stick in line with
our original decision and let an appeal
inspector work out whether that
infrastructure is actually there and
deliverable thank you for that councelor
Stringer um we now have councelor War
boys
please yes um I think I must repeat what
has been said several times before that
I there's been no
substantial changes with this planning
application
um the site is has been L has got
concerns about deliverability we haven't
mentioned earlier that there is just one
single access onto a site and the
recommendations that have a site that
size it should have have two
possible
um ways of actually getting in and out
of the
site um I think the
infrastructure improvements are are
actually sort of potential they aren't
being realized and I do think I
understand from this that they are
dependent on the the developments
already going on the
680 houses or so that are already being
planned for elmswell this is an
additional 10% or so on top of that and
we did mention that from highways that
though this is isn't going is going to
be manageable by the system it's going
to it will push the Junctions over
capacity
um you that by their own admissions that
these Junctions are are with the
development that's already been planned
are approaching capacity and further
devel velopment will take them over
capacity
um it's been mentioned that the
infrastructure is being proposed and I
think anic Bennett from strategic
planning policy and
infrastructure there her some says been
progress with some of the infrastructure
therefore in terms of infrastructure
needs derived there appears to be
Solutions these Solutions haven't been
firmed up they haven't been they aren't
actually there to trial I think the
notion of
having a large Primary School in Wool
pits also service CS well I think that
should be reviewed uh Council mentioned
uh postco 19 I think we do need to look
seriously at larger and larger schools
which could potentially be sites for um
the transmission
of coid 19 and other diseases but that
is something that is going to be in
review in the future and I think the
infrastructure hasn't been put there the
local community have tremendous concerns
which have been voiced by the ward
members about this impa impact on the
communities and they do not regard it as
sustainable so I feel I I I think
the though the
um
it has been questioned whether the
infrastructure needs has been satisfied
I think it is very much looking at a
half pint of beer that the glass is
either half full and half empty um and I
think
with possibly Under Pressure but I I'd
hesitate to use the word pressure having
looked at the same information again
well perhaps they' decided the
infrastructure Solutions are half full
rather than half empty I think think
these need to be tested much more
rigorously and i' like to see that
infrastructure in place before we
consider any further development at
elmswell so I don't think I'll be I
won't be supporting this
application thank you councelor War boys
um so that's now me um well I I did say
I think we're between a rock and a hard
place on this one and and I think that's
what all this planning is about it's
very difficult
um as regards the
education um I think we had somebody
present that said the number of pupils
going from woolpit to elmswell and
elmswell to woolpit were about on
parity um and I do understand what the
ward members are saying about the
difficulties of getting across the
A14 um and taking them from each another
school but um I think many villages
don't have the luxury of such close
proximity of an alternative school um so
I'm I'm
not convinced totally that the
schooling will be the primary issue of
causing grief here I do hear about the
cycle way and someone has to start
somewhere um and it does seem
unfortunate that all the other
developments have gone ahead without the
cycle way um provision being put on
their applications but it has to start
somewhere so I think we have a positive
from the point of view of a contribution
here um and the cycle way yes I know it
very well I lived at wpit so I know the
area extremely well and I know the
difficulties that are now ensuing on
both Villages
um very difficult but as we've said
before they are on the A14 Corridor and
that's unfortunately where the
developments are going ahead so I'm
listening to everybody's points of view
making notes you probably see me looking
down I'm making notes myself um and at
the moment uh I think I'll just leave it
that I'm between a rock and a hard place
but if members are minded to refuse it I
think they need to um come up with some
uh planning reasons for this but we
haven't got there yet um councelor
Caston hasn't spoken so I do need to ask
councel Casten sorry that oh no you
haven't oh sorry no I beg your pardon
you have spoken um but I'm just
finishing off now um so as regards uh my
points I'm still listening to everybody
um councel Kasten if you've put the hand
up is that for a recommendation only
please I'm sorry I I just wanted to get
your attention that I am I haven't
spoken yet have you not in this
debate I called you right at the
beginning I beg your pardon and you I
was first on list and I I wasn't ready
to speak um all right you can you can
have another first go then if you would
please and once councilor Casten has
spoken then um um if anybody wants to
make a proposal or a second a then use
the hands up function for that only so
um councelor Casten can you take your
hand down please because I've got eyes
all over the place at the moment trying
to follow this so if you would like to
speak and tell us your views thank
you thank you very much um yeah rocking
a hard place is definitely a good
description of this I remember this from
the last meeting with the um when we um
looked at this it was a very difficult
decision to make then elmswell has had a
huge amount of development and the
infrastructure is being pushed but we um
we have seen
progress a um a new Primary School in
wpit is um progress the um there's more
chance of the walking and cycle link
that's
progress would I like to I've got to ask
the question would I like to go to an
appeal and defend this using material
planning um reasons um I would find that
quite difficult um do I think it will
get through appeal I think it's got a
good chance of getting for a appeel I've
I've listened to debate and there's been
some really good um reasons but I just
don't know if we're we've got anything
strong enough and um do I think the
people of elmswell would be worse off if
this was handled in in appeal rather
than by our planning department um and
this um Committee in regards to
contributions yeah I I think they'd be
worse off we wouldn't have control over
those contributions coming in so it's
just it's a really difficult um decision
to make but I think if I was going to
put myself um in a position it would be
um over more of the um side of the fence
with approval but still you know it's
it's a very difficult um decision to um
make but I I think the only way to um
deal with this is probably to go to to
the vote on
it right um I see councelor humph and
and councelor cassen have put their
hands up at the moment um I was going to
say we take break before we do that but
as those hands are up before we go to
the break councelor humph can you tell
me yeah Madam chair thank you and um I
think councilor Caston summed it up
really really well I have listened to
debate I've listened to both sides and
you're right it's not easy um but is is
it defendable to refuse it I honestly
can't find a planning reason to refuse
this and because of that because the
comments of council Caston a moment ago
the fact there is no neighborhood plan
is not even on paper yet um
I would like to recommend
approval right and do I have a proposal
a seconder
please yes madame chairman I'll second
that that's councilor Caston well before
we
move
well we've got a vote so yes um sorry I
was going to take a break before we got
there so we have but we haven't um asked
people to speak to the motion so can we
um just have a break for um 10 minutes
or so at the moment um while we've got
that on the table and then come back and
then we can move to the second round of
people talking and talking to the motion
um so can we do that
please so um Robert Carmichael what
would you what timing would you suggest
minutes 10 minutes
okay so if if we can do that please um
can we just have a quick 10- minute
break and then we'll go around a second
time talking to the motion okay thank
you very much everybody just mute your
mics please thank
you
right chair
I right chair I've now put us back on
live so if it's okay with yourself I'll
do a roll call to just check that all
members are here yes if you would please
thank you thank
you so I just go to my list so councelor
Casten present councelor
gold present councelor Guthrie present
councel Humphries present councelor
melon present councelor Norris present
councelor
Stringer present and councelor War boy
always present thank you chair we're all
here right so um we had a proposal and a
seconder so we need to move forward down
the debate
again um
and I will leave councelor Casten till
later if I may as as one of the
proposers just for the minute unless you
want to speak now as well because I'm
going down everybody
again thank you madam chair um I um
don't really have anything to add at
this point I'll be very interested to
hear the this um Second Time Around and
just see um see what councilors are
talking about and um yeah um thank you
very much okay thank you for that
councelor Caston councelor
gold thank you uh Madam chair um
I'm with your words Rock and Hard Place
I think there are those applications
that you are happy to approve uh there
are those applications you're glad that
can be refused and for good planning
reasons and there are those uh cases
where there aren't uh you're not happy
about approving it but the fundamental
point is there aren't the planning Reon
sufficient planning reasons uh to refuse
it and I
I fear that this is one of those cases
and and that's why I'm in terms of it I
don't think it doesn't feel like and
from what I've heard and I'm grateful
for uh for for everything that's been
said and questions put but it seems to
me that there aren't the planning
reasons uh to refuse it thank you very
much thank you councelor gold um
councelor humph do you want to to speak
again now or or do you want to wait
until you've heard everyone else and
then add anything later I'm happy to
speak now actually I'm not going to
change my opinion um I stand by The
Proposal mainly because there are no
planning reasons to to refuse this and
and that's what we've got to base it on
we've all got personal opinions we all
like cars we like bikes all this side of
it but the fact is this is a planning
committee that has to work on the
planning policies and principles and I
can't find a planning reason to turn
this down so as councelor gold said yeah
it is a rocking hard place some you're
not completely happy with but it comes
down to that
what are the rules what are the
regulations does this fit in with both
of those yes it does therefore I'll
stand by The
Proposal thank you for that councelor
humph councelor
melon yes thank you chair um it's been
very interesting to listen to the debate
and um all members of the committee have
made some some very valid and strong
points um but I find myself I think
coming down on the side of uh voting
against this debate vment I think there
is we have no certainty about the link
relief road which sort long promise but
never seems to get much further forward
despite the uh the visit of a previous
Secretary of State um we have no real
progress on the cycle link um it's moved
sort of one step further in in in a 100
step process it seems to me um and I
believe there is reason to
uh planning reasons to go against this
and I turn to the um my well-worn copy
of the mppf paragraph
103 significant development should be
focused on locations which are or can be
made sustainable through limiting the
need to travel and then paragraph
104 uh minimizing the number and length
of Journeys needed for employment
shopping Leisure education and other
activity so that I think is is a
reasonable basis to to look at this um
the this application and turn it down so
I will be voting against it thank you
chair thank you for that councelor
Norris thank you uh yes I've listened to
the debate in depth uh I'm still
unconvinced regarding the infrastructure
provision and the amount of travel that
will be involved to and from schools and
the highways matters in general so I
shall be voting against this thank you
thank you councel Norris councelor W uh
councelor
Stringer chair thank you chair yes uh I
I have to say I disagree with councelor
gold in terms of his assessment uh yes
there are different types of planning
application this one falls into where
there are significant planning reasons
that support this and that don't support
this uh and I favor those policies there
many policies that don't support this
application for instance the mppf one of
of the overarching parts of sustainable
development is the Environmental
Objective C uh and this fails on C on a
number of points won't read it out
because I haven't got the time it fa
fails our own joint local plan
allocations policy it fails uh uh fc1
CS3 H7 CS6 cs1 and more importantly it
fails the first paragraph for the
refusal on page
115 the the last sentence says as
sustainable development supported by
services and benefiting from suitable
access to those services I don't believe
this site has suitable access why if
even if in the very near future we build
all of the cycleways and all of the new
routes in elmw to wpit to walk to school
from here you first start walking in the
opposite
direction you then go in another
opposite direction before you can turn
back on yourself walking a little bit
closer to the school and then you walk
in another opposite
direction this is not this is this fails
on a fundamental pillar of sustainable
development and and as the ward member
said busing children around in a in a
village of this size and someone did
have the Freudian slip and call it a
town you know is actually it it fails
all of that pillar of the same now the
officers yes County officer said we can
accommodate those people we'll just give
us the money and we'll bust them around
that is not sustainable totally
unsustainable according to the mppf and
all of our own policies our joint local
plan recognized this which is why we
didn't allocate the site the other issue
uh that I have is we refused a site at
Harley park because the children had to
be busted from there to get to the
nearest school that distance was less
than the distance we're proposing busing
these pupils to W it so frankly uh I
think this fails on many planning fronts
uh and I will be sticking with the
original decision to refuse this
application for the original reasons it
doesn't have suitable access to those
many services thank you chair thank you
councelor Stringer councelor War
boys yes I I I'll be I'll be brief I
think I think if we voted to support
this application we'd be voting against
our own planning policies uh as Council
norrris pointed out page 21 The Proposal
would expand elmswell further than what
is being strategically planned for I
don't think highways nor suff County
Council education department have come
up with um
convincing
uh outcomes for Future travel uh it is
going to be a congested Junction and the
proposals this further develop
would
um take it even further I'll just this
is the the plan for oh it's not going to
come up is it but the plan for elmswell
it shows a ring of proposed sites around
elmswell and this is just taking it that
one step too far we don't have existing
infrastructure concrete infrastructure
in place to support further
development thank you for
that uh well that now comes down to
myself
um and there are compelling arguments on
on both sides
um but I do think there has been a
move that some of the issues
can be accommodated orbe it a little
down the
line
um I think that's where I am at the
moment is that I honestly cannot
find what the specific harm is um and
what the unacceptable harm in planning
terms is because everybody will argue
their point um
robustly and we can't go back to the
original refusal
um and although we've had C Sal's advice
from uh the applicant
side uh shown to us it is council's
advice and they are very professional
people um
so I will be voting uh with the proposal
at the
moment so with that in mind we need to
go to to a vote
[Applause]
please thank you chair sorry chair
that's all
right right so let just get the
right so if you could please respond
with for against or
abstain so councelor James Kasten for
the proposal
councelor Peter
gold
four councelor cath gri
four councelor Barry humre
four councelor Andrew
melon
against councelor Mike
Norris
against councelor Andrew Stringer
against and councelor Roland War boys
against Mr depre I make that a tie do
can you please confirm yes uh hello uh
good good morning everyone yes I I agree
four votes to four it's a tie so it is
chair's casting
vote uh can I have time out for some
legal advice on this one please um
certainly Madam chairman if you wish yes
yes so can can we uh stop the debate at
the moment while I have time out with
the legal officer y I'll do that now
chair
uh in this instance um I'm not going to
use my casting vote and what that means
is that the motion will fail however
what I propose is that we defer to go
for a risk assessment to find out what
unacceptable and specific harm would be
and the effects and consequences should
we um look for um a refusal at a later
date but that's what I will be looking
for so can I have a seconder for us to
defer for a risk assessment C councelor
Humphries yeah Madam chair's propos it
yeah I accept that that that'd be fine
but can I have from um from Robert
carmichel that the motion uh that was
originally proposed has failed and we
now have a new proposal and
seconder yes thank you chair so with
regards to the point on
um the chairman not using their casting
vote as we saw previously at
Council um it's a choice of the chair um
to break deadlock specifically or if
they choose not to use it the motion
Falls um it's guidance that's within NES
which is our Bible in committee's terms
um and um I think I'll leave it there
chair but if there's any other questions
I'm more than happy to
respond and thank you for that so I have
a proposal well I've proposed that we
defer um to look at risks um
unacceptable harm should this be refused
and what the effects and consequences
were so we will ask the officers to go
back for that um I have a seconder um
Robert do we need to talk to that or can
we just go straight to the
vote uh if there's anyone that does wish
to comment chair I would recommend
everyone being the opportunity to have
a that's helpful I'll just run through
everyone councelor Kasten no comments
thank you councelor gold happy with the
proposer councelor humph is obviously
you're a seconder but your comments
please thank you councelor
melon no comments chair thank you
councelor Norris agree to the proposal
councelor wbor
agree to deferring yes and councelor
Stringer agree thank you very much may
we go to the vote please
Robert thank you thank you chair I think
that Mr depre was Mr depre did you wish
to come in there sorry very briefly Sor
yeah thank you um just to say I agree
yeah no no no quite right I mean just
because we had a bit of a long
discussion I think the Sor adjournment I
meant to say just for the sake of
transparency to confirm you madam
chairman you took my le advice and you
spoke to Mr carmichel as well at my
suggestion and yeah I I'm quite content
that what what you've just done is is is
perfectly lawful in accordance with um
the uh Constitution and procedures of of
the council um now and we have a
resolution now on the table which um I
think is is is well understood and it
can be formulated for the minutes Mr
Carmichael you're quite content with
that I'm assuming from what we've just
just been saying
um
that so if I may just clarify and I
think Mr pman G might want to jump in
that the proposal is well I mean one one
side of it is that we we often other
councils have used the term risk
assessment that in effect there is a an
assessment by the officers and advice to
members who of course Remain the
decision makers as to what the um
consequences of a refusal might be but
was it
also your wish to instruct the officers
to advise you further on the um
potential possible um infrastructure
reasons for refusal which the um report
indicated hadn't been very strongly
clarified is that is that where we are
if I understood
correctly well no I just I what I wanted
was if if if there there is a refusal
what the unacceptable harm in planning
terms and um what what specific harm
could be to the effects and consequence
should a refusal be uh put forward I I
understand thank you yeah
understand so that that's all I need to
say at the moment then thank you thank
you for your support thank
you right CH if there's no one else that
wishes to speak then um sorry I'm I may
I come in sorry
John um um
I'm this this is something new in my
experience so I'm just being sure that
I'm got this right here um we are
looking to defer this for a risk
assessment on the consequences of if
members refuse so therefore what are the
planning
consequences of a refusal whatever the
reason for that refusal might be but it
is not for officers to come up with
reasons for refusal
just look at the consequences of if
there was a refusal or whatever reason
for refusal that might be if Mr pman if
I might come in again Madam chairman Mr
pman it's um I hesitate to say this
because every Council has his own way of
doing things but as you know I also work
for West suffer Council and um that it
is a fairly not
uncommon part of their procedure there
that if it's officers advising committee
that's an intended refusal or for that
matters occasionally an intended
approval is strongly contrary to
officers advice and there is fear and
and worry on our part as the
consequences of it there is a risk
assessment taken back to the next
committee rather than an an an outright
refusal or permission cont advice o of
the um potential consequences of the
decision I mean obviously stating the
obvious those those consequences may
include uh losing an inquiry severely
and possibly facing costs I mean
sometimes a council makes a decision
that's a risky once to take that's a
decision that Mr pton G you and I have
to respect sometimes but I think that's
why I put what I I said to the the
chairman a minute ago because there are
two aspects of this that you we we we
can look at the um for me and advise
members on the um the the risk in terms
of the um this not being upheld and then
the consequences of that but also I
think what what the committee as you say
it's not for officers to come up with
members reasons for refusal
but it's I think that the chairman was
perhaps looking for advice on the um
potential arguable um adverse harm
that's not been adequately identified so
far I see the Chairman's nodding
yes my my my only concern is that the
extent of risk that can be analyzed by
officers is going to be limited because
we don't have potential reasons for
refusal before us but I appreciate
that's not the position we're
in
okay um just uh from the point of view
in do we have to put some some things
down that have been discussed I mean I'm
I'm not going to put words into um uh
people who've said no but they quite
eloquently said no why they don't want
but whether I agree with that or not is
a different question so I don't want to
put um points down um from Ian's point
of view um from the other Council um
have they taken it as an overall thing
when they've done it before in your
other um councils indeed um I'm I'm I'll
come back again yeah I mean I've not re
because I because I'm more I tend to
concentrate more on babber and mids
suffk as you know because I I've not
been to West suffer committee recently
but I think it would certainly be the
the there would be a awareness of the
officers and there might be a note and
in the resolution that's parted to defer
as to what um obviously as to why
the um majority of the committee are
unhappy with the recommendation and want
to refuse so the officers know what
they're taking away and what they want
need to come back with so in fact we've
got a a general list of of what um
people who would vote against it we've
got a general list of that and that's
what we're asking the officers to look
at is is that your view I yeah yes
because I mean what what happens at w as
I say and and West suffk isn't the only
place where the officers go away and say
look we we've respectfully heard what
members say members are saying x y and
Zed and we we are assessing and what
members have said and replying as it
were advising them on really our
professional View and if necessary
somebody outsides professional as to um
the the strength of that and the risks
can we just hold the meeting a minute
I've got somebody rather rudely banging
at the door will you just hold the
meeting one moment
please
yeah well I think weit coun for for a
few seconds councelor humph is in the
chair I
think I
I'll yeah and we'll we'll just wait
until she comes
back I do apologize I had a lorry
driving up here and banging on the door
and I'm really sorry to the whole
Community but also just to um let people
know that Sarah Manel was a little bit
out of uh the initial restart is that
correct
Sarah uh yeah I um I I could see your
mouths moving but I couldn't hear
anything and I I think it's that my
speakers were on um mute but it doesn't
show you that it only has mic on mute as
a symbol okay well what what what's
happened is I haven't used my um
Chairman's casting vote so the motion
fails but what I have proposed is that
we defer it and it's been seconded to
have a risk assessment done to find any
unacceptable harm in planning terms and
be specific on effects and consequences
so that the officers can go away and
come back and in has been explaining um
have you been listening to Ian's
explanation yeah I've I've heard I think
I got back in when Ian was talking yeah
so um Robert and Ian is that fine for
Sarah to continue with the vote that
we've
got not voting I just I was just
interested to know what was happening
I'm not I'm not one of the members who's
voting oh I think you it's not it's not
an issue from that point of view so
thank you very much for running through
that sorry I'm in the muddle right okay
so um have we got to the point where we
can take a vote now
in um Mr Mr carmichel as long as you're
content if this resolution is passed you
know what to put in the minutes and and
and we know what resolution we're
passing or if we do pass it
I believe so if Mr Mr pman could just
confirm and clarify so that we can
record it in
perpetuity yeah
John there really all the objections
that the the
people I'm sorry I I I I don't find it
acceptable that officers will need to SI
through the whole meeting to pull out
their interpretation of what objections
have been expressed in the debate okay
well I've put the proposal forward so
then um I think we've got things such as
they don't find it acceptable for the
schooling to be um going from one
Village to another there was a highways
issue that they were unhappy with there
was the fact that the jlp doesn't
allocate the site there was the fact
that the um neighborhood plan doesn't
allocate the site um what else was there
um but but it it needs to these are
reasons for possibly refusing the
application in terms of the expressed
idea that they cause harm to these
issues I thought we started this this uh
conversation in terms of what is the
risk of a refusal what is the corporate
risk of a refusal what is the um appeal
risk of a refusal yes not necessarily
would that be based on specifics of
trying to find a planning harm
that's not what this is about is looking
at the consequences of refusal
regardless of what reason that might
be well I think if I may Madam chairman
Mr pman G yes that the West I I won't I
won't keep calling it The West suffet
practice because this this Council has
its own Integrity as a as a as a public
body and it does what it but it's just I
think the suggestions been made that we
we we do um this and thisa on this
occasion um for particular reasons that
yes you Mr Pon you've correctly
identified my um suggestion based on
nearby practice was that we that there
isn't there is a risk assessment of the
consequences of a refusal and that's the
appeal risk and other Associated risks I
think as part of that I think to assist
um officers doing that task as much as
as possible they they can assess the
appeal risk um it as it
were in any
event in a broad sense but it would be I
think that the chairman has just
identified um the what would be the if
we had if the committee had been
persuaded to vote positively for a
refusal if you see what I mean today
that that that what the chairman has
just outlined are the um are the basis
for such refusal if I've understood
correctly I mean if everybody will bear
with us I did take legal advice and we
had a legal conversation and um you know
I'm I'm hoping that this will be a
positive positive way forward to bottom
out issues that may still concern
people okay um if I can
assist at the moment I taking on board
terms that we are deferring for a risk
assessment on the consequences of a
refusal yeah I would not want to
premeditate any reasons for that refusal
oh okay I thought you were asking for
them right
understood and consequently cause a
concern with any return that this
application would have to committee okay
understood I think that's probably as
far as I can take this without entering
off into unknown territory and causing
us even more
confusion wish to confuse John y
okay yeah so I think that's the point I
understand and I want to keep it as
short and sweet as that and then we can
back I'm happy with your guidance on
that and I'm very grateful it is a first
time for all of us on
this okay thanks John and and thank you
in right Robert would you like to take a
roll call on what we've proposed now um
so um John um last statement is what
we're looking at on a deferral for a
risk assessment thank you thank you
chair so if you if members could please
respond with four against or abstain so
councelor James carsten
four councelor Peter
gold
four councelor Kathy Guthrie
four councel Barry Humphries
four councelor Andrew melon
four councelor Mike Norris
four councelor Andrew Stringer
four and councelor Roland War boys four
thank you chair I make that unanimous Mr
depre do you
confirm am I unmuted now can I be heard
yes yes I agree that was a unanimous
vote for the
[Music]
resolution thank you for that um well as
I mentioned earlier um it's
non-pecuniary liability I shall be
stepping aside for the next item and
councelor Humphrey's will be taking that
item and it's up to councelor Humphrey's
now to say um if he wishes to continue
or whatever so I will now um Step Aside
thank you very much M chair thank you
I'll take over the chair for uh this
which is agenda 7B on page 147 of your
papers DC stroke2 stroke 0148 and that's
for the grant granting the outline um
outline position with conditions for
change of use for stationing of five
holiday lodges and the officer for this
is
Brun good morning chair members
afternoon actually it is now isn't it
hello everybody um and thanks for having
me I just realized this is my first
committee for about five and a half
years so apologies if it all goes wonky
but let's give it a try let's start with
the presentation there's no late papers
to report so I'm going to get straight
into the present ation with your
permission so the application site is
ston and Barnes pet road stonom
aspo going to run you through the aerial
photographs to give you the context of
the site ston ands members may or may
not be familiar with the complex Leisure
complex um various tourism and Leisure
facilities in the countryside Just
Between The Villages of stamas and Peta
this wider aerial view gives you sorry
BR I don't think you're sharing your
screen ah right
sorry
again is that
better perfect that's fine right let's
start again I told you it would go wrong
right so ston and
barns
um this first aerial view gives you um a
shot it's it's a little bit old but um
it gives you a shot of the site showing
the part of the site where the proposal
is uh you're looking straight down onto
the two fishing lakes and part of the
existing complex of holiday lodges
around one of the fishing lakes the site
as members may or may not know part of a
Leisure and tourism complex in the
countryside between Villages of stomas
which you can see in this wider aerial
map on the left of the orange blob which
is the application site and Peta along
towards the
right so the application site the orange
L shape on this constraints map sits
between two sections of
existing Caravans laid out around the
fishing lakes portion of the Leisure
complex um the constraints here show two
listed buildings that we have um close
by so just a a little bit more detail on
the application site and how it relates
to the existing complex of Caravans
around the fishing
lakes I'm going to run you through the
photographs in a moment um and just to
to let you know that there's some video
in there which I'm hoping will work
fairly well just to show you the context
so the proposal is for the use of land
for the sighting of an additional five
Caravans for Holiday use so this site
layout plan shows you the indicative
layout of Caravans within the L-shaped
site and how they relate to the other
Caravans on the site um the precise
layout will be governed by S site
licensing and separation distancing but
that's that would be how it would
would be
arranged
and this is a photograph leading from
the access road that goes between the
two lakes and the two parts of the
complex which have the The Lodges either
side so the left hand side of this
picture is the northern side of the
complex the right being the southern
side and I'm standing just at the edge
of the car parking area for
this and then into the site itself so
you can see there in the top right is
the corner of the access roadway which
leads onto the L-shaped grass area which
is the application site
bordered by some whip planting to the
boundaries and then I'm turning around
to show you the um wider landscape
looking towards the main road so this is
going this view is going um North
Northeast toward towards
Peta and then looking more Northerly in
this picture turning around now looking
more Westerly back towards the complex
of existing Caravan lodges around the
complex this is the video so I'm hoping
this
will give you a bit of a better idea of
the context and I'm hoping it works
okay
e
okay sorry if that made you a bit dizzy
but hopefully it gave you an idea of the
context of the site right on the the
edge of the two I don't play it
again let's go forward okay and then
we've got some um pictures here from the
road so that you can see the view from
the public Highway um and you'll note
from some of the um objections raised
the landscape impact is one of the
issues so you can see in the background
there the two sections of the existing
complex of
Caravans and the Fairly open aspect
across the fields from the
highway and again this is from the 1120
highway just looking towards the site
this is a bit of video just showing you
a bit of the context of that
landscape so it's Wide Open Fields over
towards
Peta and just showing the edge of the St
bonds complex
there believe that's it so I'm going to
take us back
to the layout
plan um yes so the proposal is for five
additional holiday
Caravans um it's relevant to note that
members granted permission for
development at the site comprising the
existing holiday Caravans back in 2015
they are subject to a condition
controlling their occupancy for Holiday
use um with a break clause for one month
of the year The Proposal before you is a
recommendation of granting permission
subject to condition which is the same
as the condition that controls the other
lodges I think that's it if anyone has
any
questions thank you Brun and I think the
video worked really well sort of allowed
us to get a feel for the actual area so
that's nice thank you we'll go to
questions for the officer and we'll go
alphabetically in Reverse so start
councelor War boys
please
um yes so I think it's this is a a
detailed planning application isn't it
so would we be put in
uh uh uh Reserve matters with regard to
sort of um how carbon neutral the
buildings would
be um so they're not buildings uh the
the application is for the use of land
so you are granting permission if you're
minded to do so for the use of land for
Caravans Caravans have to comply with a
legal definition but that legal
definition is just to do with their
size um and their transportability
attachment to the ground that sort of
thing so um they don't have the
same scope I suppose for um carbon
reduction um priorities as a constructed
building
does I think also um this is outlined
planning permission so Reserve matters
will come is that all your questions
Council War boys yes I just wonder where
where in fact that would come in because
it was one of the um concerns of St Mel
Parish
Council okay uh councelor Stringer
please any questions sorry may I just
interject it's a full planning
application this one it's not an outline
uh okay that may there may be a typo on
the report I apologize if that's the
case no that's fine is everybody I come
into that yeah just if I may come on
that one I apologies uh on page 147 it
is noted that it says Grant outline
planning permission that is incorrect it
should be uh planning permission so this
is a full planning application and it's
referring to the change of use so what
we're dealing with essentially is the
change of use of the land for the
stationary uh stationary of uh holiday
lodges on top the holiday lodges
themselves are deemed to be effectively
a caravan uh be a static one but be it
constructed to look like Lodge but it's
the change of use to allow that Lodge on
top of that land that we are referring
to
here thank you apologies accepted um
therefore remove the word outline from
the title and we'll continue um
councelor Stringer please yeah thank you
chair you mentioned a condition that
restricts the use uh does the existing
condition
work that's a good question thank you um
I think counselor is alluding to the
history of complaints um relating to the
breach of the condition for some of the
Caravans on the site um the enforcement
team are working quite hard to ensure
compliance with the condition it is it
is a known issue at this site that we
have alleges of breach of the condition
what that means is the the condition
wording says that the uh the holiday
Caravans shall only be occupied for 11
months of the year and there is a a
one-month break clause and there are
allegations that um the residents have
been in occupation during that period um
there was some enforcement investigation
carried out during the break Clause
period of this year and there has been
some ongoing um
action uh pcns in particular served by
the enforcement team there's no current
enforcement notice in forc
um on the site but there have been there
have been pcns and there are um ongoing
investigations working with the the land
owner and the
residents councilor string is that all
your
questions yes thanks chair thank you and
Council Norris
please well thank you yes I'm aware of
the ongoing enforcement actions um no
other questions thank you thank you you
Mel councilor melon please uh thank you
chair um the one of the consulty
comments refers to um a previously
agreed master plan for ston and Barnes
um Can the officer just sort of confirm
whether such a plan is in place and and
how that stands in planning terms yes
indeed so the master plan I'm saying
that in adverted commas even though you
can't see it is um what is referred to
as the the the um the 2015 planning
permission so that's detailed in your
papers um it is called master plan
generally because it dealt with a a a
considerable number of different
development elements on the site to both
regularize um a series of
inconsistencies and unauthorized
developments that had had had
accumulated but also to deal with some
prospective development so that
permission exists and it is um still
relevant in part it has been
superseded in part by some additional
developments that have happened and some
changes to some of the developments that
have that that permission permitted um
this um part of the site the fishing
lakes and the um Caravans around it that
this proposal will add to was part of
that um 2015 permission and that 2015
permission is the one that includes the
condition
that the holiday Caravans have a break
Clause so it still exists it's still
extent and it's still in force
um and there are elements of it that as
I say are have been changed by
additional development and there are
current applications to change more bits
of it um just as the as the business at
the site um
evolves okay thank you no further
questions
ch thank you and uh Council go
please no questions thank you chair
Council
Caston thank you very much Mr chairman
um in regards to the um the specific
requirement in this of um
screening um what does this term
screening mean is it completely screened
is it partially screened um and from
what
position um does it have have to be
screened from like is it floor level or
um or where
please sorry um so yeah landscape
screening so um that doesn't mean that
um landscape planting to a degree where
all you will see is trees and hedges and
no part of the development that's not
going to be a reasonable expectation and
from what you can see from the
photographs and video that that I showed
in the presentation there have been
Landscaping conditions um which have
been implemented um and are partly
maturing already but you can still see
that there is development there um so
what if we add to that and ensure the
appropriate boundary treatments and
Landscape screening of this part of the
development it won't mean that you can't
see anything or that it will look like a
woodland uh it would just mean that it
will mitigate the harshness of the edge
of the development as it transitions
into the open Countryside so you'll get
a bit of
softer treatment to that edge and as you
can see from the photographs which I can
show again if if you'd like to there
some of that planting is already in
place there's some whip planting um
which actually marks the outside of this
site
and there's a bond as well which I think
you could just get in one of the
photographs which has been constructed a
while
back would you like me to reshow any of
those photographs um no I I did unless
other members would like to see them I I
did look at them at the time so um
there's no um there's there's no
height um the minimum height that that
screening has to be is that is that true
members can um include that in a
condition it has happened happened in
the past where we have required the
planting of a hedge for example that to
be allowed to grow to a height of X
meters and thereafter rain no lower than
that height but that that
becomes
um a a little bit more difficult and
onerous on us to ensure compliance with
um but but it is technically possible to
do we have had conditions like that
elsewhere
um it would be um inconsistent with what
we have on the rest of the site however
previous decisions that members have
taken have just required
Landscaping schemes to be agreed without
specifying um that they reach a
particular
height okay thank
you okay uh braon I have a question so
there was some talk about loss of
agricultural land by the parish council
when I saw your picture it seems that
the area where the Caravans are going to
be cited is actually marked by loose
planting behind it does that mean that
agricultural line is not taking away any
further land than what we saw on the
actual uh picture that showed
us yeah this land is already in the
ownership of the applicant um so it's
not in in Practical use for agriculture
um it is just that small area that you
could see outlined so in terms of its
functionality for agricultural purposes
it would be very limited especially
given that it's enclosed by the rest of
the complex and it's an awkward shape
and that makes things just makes things
harder to get Machinery in and and work
land when it's like that great thank you
okay um thank you Braun um we'll now
move on we've got no objetive we've got
no supporter we do have a member of the
parish ston as Parish Council and that's
Mr emberson if you'd like to give us
your three minutes and Robert you'll be
doing the timing thank you Mr chair
before I commence a statement uh would
you allow me to correct the planning
officer on a very important point that
she made earlier or
not no I'll hear your I'll hear your
first thank you okay thank you uh good
oh good afternoon the current mids local
plan states that static Caravans and
holiday chalets can only be permitted
where there is no adverse effects on the
character and appearance of the
landscape the existing residential
immunity and only where Services can be
provided the emerging joint local plan
also states that tourism and Leisure
officer supported in principle but were
appropriate in scale character and
nature of their locality using either
plan as a guide the expansion of the
ston and barns Caravan Park is not
appropriate in terms of its scale its
character or its nature the site is
already the size of a small village
having permission for 172 static
Caravans plus additional touring
Caravans across the site this is totally
out of character for the local area and
please remember that a static caravan by
law can be up to 20 m in length by 6.8 M
wide equal to 136 square m of living
space this compares to an average newb
buil four-bedroom home that occupies no
more than 139 square
meters there are concerns over the
utilities infrastructure on the site
occupiers have previously complained of
inadequate water sewage and electricity
supplies and during rainy periods
localized flooding there have been water
shortages power outages and overflow of
sewage into the surrounding ditches and
water courses the site simply cannot
cope with the number of Caravans there
at present and this is with less than
2third of the permitted Caravans
currently in place as evident since the
original application was granted neither
ston and barns management nor planning
enforcement have been able to control
the unlawful residential occupation of
the existing
Caravans there are currently at least 14
active enforcement notices in relation
to the site so until planning can
enforce the current planning conditions
no further expansion should even be
considered
and to correct the planning officer the
condition states that the site is open
for 11 months but it's for Holiday use
only not for sole or main
occupation the original planning
permission of 2018 was held as a new
chapter in the SES planning history the
number and location of lodges were set
by the master plan to ensure there was
no overdevelopment of the site and the
development would have no unacceptable
impacts the importance of the location
and the number of holiday accommodation
units was clear as any intensification
of use would have a significant adverse
material effect this application
undermines this principle the parish
council objects the above application
and respect respectfully requests the
local planning Authority refuse the
application the proposed development is
in contrary to the development plan it
is completely unsustainable and there
are no material considerations to
outweigh these facts thank
you thank you very much um questions
then councelor War boys
no questions at this no
questions councelor
Stringer no questions councelor Norris
no questions thank you counc
melon uh yes thank you CH I've got one
um um Mr emberson you you mentioned that
uh there's 172 I think static
Caravans approved but they're not all on
site or can you just clarify that around
the figures of what's on site and what
isn't from your um we've um we've had a
count of approximately 125 currently on
site out of the
172 okay thank you no further questions
Council gold uh no questions thanks and
councelor
Casten thank you chair Mr emberson you
said about the um issues with sewage
going into um ditches do you have any
proof or any reference
to yes it was reported to the
environment agency uh it was
towards I believe it was uh September
October of
2019 um and sewage was flowing into into
the local ditches uh the issue the issue
was the
um I would call them cesspit water
treatment plants um that are on site um
however whyever they blocked up
overflowed uh and we had that that
situation um ston and
Barnes
flushed used uh bore hole water to flush
the ditches and the water courses
through however envir the environment
agency was made aware and they
investigated um they they have not
updated us since that time as to what
they're as to what their conclusions
were or what their investigations
concluded J thank you
okay uh thank you and um I have no
questions actually so thank you for your
time and uh thank you for three minutes
no thank you very
much okay we're now going to go on to
the applicant or agent is Mr cobal
around
uh we don't have anyone uh registered to
speak as the applicant chair thank you
in that case we'll go to the ward member
which is um councelor Susan Moy and I
believe you're going to uh read out a
speech that she's prepared because she
had to leave yes thank you chair so um
counc Council moly unfortunately sends
her um apologies but she was she had to
attend another meeting
so this is the latest application to
provide five addition additional holiday
lodges on protected Greenfield land this
proposal is contrary to the development
plan it is an archetype of unsustainable
development and to my mind there are no
material considerations weighing in
support of it the application site is
outside the settlement boundary of ston
aspel in planning policy terms it is
Countryside development in the
countryside is
restricted the planning permission
reference
31515 issued on the TW 12 of October
2018 Master planning permission was
hailed as a new chapter in this SES
planning history encompassing and
addressing all the matters considered
outstanding at that time covering both
new development and the regularization
of all unauthorized development on the
site the various elements covered by the
master planning permission have been
carefully assessed and the conditions
attached to it were imposed to minimize
and mitigate the developments impact on
the surrounding area whether by reason
of visual immunity highway safety
environmental Heritage Etc impacts the
location and number of holiday lodges
were a very important part of the
planning balance the number and location
of The Lodges was set by the master plan
for the whole site to ensure that that
there is no harmful over development at
the site that the development does not
have unacceptable impacts for example on
the landscape and that the living
conditions of those occupying the
holiday lodges are not
compromised the planning statement
describes the proposed location as a gap
and the development as infilling an
existing Gap it is not a gap the
proposed five to additional units would
be on open Greenfield land outside the
shielding effect of the Landscaping Bond
a further unacceptable encroachment into
the countryside landscape the proposed
five additional holiday lodges would
lead to the intensification of the use
and would en enable unacceptable
overdevelopment on an already unsuitable
site in the countryside outside the
settlement
boundary whilst the scale of the
proposed development at first glance
appears modest when considered in the
context of the ston and barn site and
with the cumulative impact it would be a
fully unsustainable development PTO
Parish Council comments regarding the
salami slicing tactics must be
recognized for what they are the
proposed development is contrary to the
statutory development
plan in addition the proposed
development is not a sustainable
development the proposed development
fails all three dimensions of the mppf
sustainability test the economic d
mention the jobs at ston and bars have
been used over and over again by the
applicant without evidence economic
benefit from five additional units is
minimal the social Dimension is again
completely lacking and the environmental
Dimension is negative as the proposal
will lead to further loss of the
Greenfield land and adverse impact on
the environment both natural and
built and that's comments from councelor
Susie moley
chair thank you um un so we can't ask a
question so that that was the statement
take from it what you wish but we we'll
now move into debate um so we'll start
with Council of War boys
please
right
oh there we go uh yeah um I'm almost
confess I'm not finding
anything uh very positive about this
lication I I have got serious concerns
about the U the uh comments by stonum
Asel PC about the robustness of the
electricity and foul water
infrastructure which this um development
would further
stress um I I I there is a a sort of
landscaping uh proposals attached to the
planning application that's already
being granted which uh was a
a sort of tidying up of
developments I I think this development
should have a a
landscaping um proposals attached to it
particularly as it's so visual from the
road um and though these are Caravans or
portable cabins or whatever I think the
design of them again it should be
specified that these are carbon neutral
actually sort
of continuing to heat and cook with gas
I mean this is this is um a retrograde
step as far as sort of trying to achieve
carbon neutrality although it is still
legal for the next few years um so on
design
um Landscaping lack of landscaping and
concerns about the infrastructure to
support it I can't I I I wouldn't I
wouldn't be happy to accept it I do
realize there argu
economic arguments
um uh for the viability of ston Asel as
a a business um I think if anything
improving landscape improving design
improving robustness of infrastructure
would actually sort of enhance that
um and I had one question which uh it
was about protected Greenfield land it
was the first sentence I think in uh
councilor
uh the ward memb uh statement in what
way is this protected is it just normal
agricultural land or is the sort of
special
landscape status
attached braon if you could answer that
please because obviously we've not got
the war member here yeah uh there's no
special designation affecting this land
doesn't lie within a special landscape
area it's not Greenfield in statutory
term um and there's no other statut
definition or a designation or policy
designation affecting it no so the so
the only comments I can make on that had
to do with the fact that uh the it this
the development could be mitigated by
improved
Landscaping yeah thank you uh councilor
Stringer thank you chair one of the
questions I've got already been answered
can before I go too much further can
someone tell me why this application is
controversial uh and here CU U you we
have you quite a lot of hurdles to get
this commit I just wonder why this one's
here uh not that not that it downplays
the severity of the application I just
wonder why it's here
um uh I have to say it's this is one of
those applications for me that's just a
bit annoying uh but I think there's
there there's another fundamental part
of this application is I don't see a
plan of where the sewage system is
because this is utterly vital You'
basically bu a new Village and and and
if you've got in I mean septic tanks or
you biodisk plants whatever you you you
can only use so many of them and they
they rely on very good quality water
percolation and I don't see any water
percolation test I see nothing here that
substantiates that if you were to put
these units here that they would be able
to you know get get water away from them
successfully uh because obviously you it
needs to cuz there's a fishing lake near
it and and there's you know and and the
environmental health of those that will
live around it so I I don't see a plan
of how this can actually be achieved
using a sustainable drainage system
thank you chair thank you and um Bron if
you could answer that please does it
feed into the normal series system
that's actually there in place at the
moment yeah so to answer the first
question the reason for the
controversial nature of the application
it was considered by the chief planning
officer that due to the um background of
the developments of the site and the
sensitivity of the site and the concerns
raised by the parish councils and the
local community that's why it's referred
to members um to do with the seage The
Proposal is that the sewage will be
dealt with by a package treatment plant
so as Council Stringer says a biodisk
type um mechanism that's not something
where we would usually ask for
significant additional details because
um that is covered by separate regime so
in the case of buildings building
controls in the case of Caravan site
licensing so we don't as standard ask
for that information if it's something
that members feel concerned about we can
ask for additional information um
perhaps to to clarify on that point but
the uh the application is proposing
package treatment
plants can can I just come in here um if
if you had this number of dwellings you
would not allow these at a planning
stage to be using biodisk plants you
just wouldn't do it uh this magnitude of
of development numbers of development
and amount of potential sewage should
have a you know should be connected to a
proper main sewer um because there is
only so many of those plants you can put
in before the whole system starts to
fail and if I don't see a plan to show
that that can actually be delivered how
can we possibly agree more added to a
system that that is that may not be up
to
scratch okay I I get your point um I'll
jump in with uh Mr Payton G just to
answer that question in terms of this
isn't technically a development so so
where do we sit on that one on that
particular question from councilor
Stringer H that's an interesting one um
in terms of you know when we normally
deal with holiday Lodgers they're
they're fairly self-contained little
units that deal with their own waste in
their own regard and we're dealing with
here is a larger site but what this
application before us is only for five
um I would probably need to think about
that a little bit more because I we can
certainly impose a further condition uh
to seek out uh notwithstanding the
details presented uh for details of a
drainage to be agreed with us if there
is a concern specifically on drainage
I'm just quickly scanning through uh the
correspondence that we've had back and I
can't see any concerns over drainage uh
being raised there's nothing from our
environmental health Team um I'm just
trying to think do we have anything from
angular water Bon when I can't see
anything and would we probably wouldn't
have needed to consult them because of
course this is just for Holiday ledgers
in the St for
this
um the answer is we would not normally
need to go thus far with this type of
application and I appreciate the
definition between a dwelling and a
holiday let is perhaps at the heart of
that
conversation thank you I can help much
further sorry well Ju Just Have a think
anyway um but yeah I'll get your point
this isn't like a Housing Development
this is Caravans five Caravans and while
we're on that subject of course the
previous applications haven't really got
a bearing on this we're looking at this
for this particular application as it's
laid down in front of us although
obvious vivly you got things going on in
your back of your mind we need to
consider it as a as an application in
its own right okay uh Council string any
other questions
sorry no no that's all I've got thank
you chair thank you um and on to
councelor Norris
please thank you yes uh if I heard
correctly there are 172 units approved
on this site and there are currently 125
on the site so immediately comes to mind
why do we need it and another five units
on the site we've heard there are
existing F water issues electricity
Supply outages and flooding with this
present number of units so I question
the whole sustainability of the site and
I don't think I will be able to support
the recommendation thank
you okay thank you and moving on then to
C Council
melon um yeah thank you Mr chair um yeah
I think um councel Norris has put it
pretty well um I just had a query on I'm
assuming pretty much this sort of
development would not make any kind of
sill uh contribution but I guess they
they they pay business rates for the
site can can the officer just confirm
that I can confirm that our charging
schedule charge is zero for Caravan so
it would make no seal
contribution um our business rate
it it would depend on how it would the
unit would be occupied as regards
taxation um quite often holiday lodges
are Council taxed rather than business
rates there's business rates payable on
parts of the rest of the complex where
there are shops and restaurants and uh
Leisure facilities I'd have to double
check as far as I know the other
occupied lodges are under council tax
regime okay thank you yeah um so yeah I
mean I pretty much feel that um if
they've got permission for 172 and they
haven't filled those yet I'm a little
bit uh unlikely to support a further
five um until that you know that site is
already filled that's sort of where I am
standing at the moment but I'll hear
what others have to say thank you chair
thank you chair sorry to interject would
you like some additional information on
the on the background to do with the
numbers yeah please I think it'd help
everybody okay so um part of the um
objective of the developer is to attract
a holiday company H Seasons I believe
are interested in this particular site
and they need to have a certain number
of Caravans permitted in order to be
able to carry forward their business
model that's very interesting thank you
um okay moving on then to counselor gold
thank you thank you chair and um yeah
that that that was useful having that
information because um I I thought
councelor Norris did put things uh very
well in relation to that I also need to
add to my definition of types of
planning application councelor string is
one of annoying because I think there is
an a feel of this one that puts it in
that category for me I would want as um
I think as a um as a minimum uh to to
take up the point about having a
condition regarding uh drainage and
other aspects of the sustainability of
the site uh here um but I I'll listen to
the rest of the debate thank you thank
you and councilor Casten
please thank you very much Mr chairman
um I think car an are a good lowcost
option for family holidays good for the
suffk economy good for employment um
looking at the harm caused by these um
this development of five
Caravans um on that occupation for 11
months I think that um um as long as
that's carried out and enforced and we
make sure that that carries on if host
seasons are coming in it seems
likely um that will be the case um I do
have concerns that there's been an
investigation into pollution caused by
the existing ones um there's potential
of overuse of a um B hole without an
extraction license all of which are
covered by other um enforcement um
processes outside of this process that
we're doing here today um I am
I the position I'm in at the moment is
yes I think I think it is acceptable I
think the um there isn't the level of
harm that would make me um want to
refuse this but I would like to agree
with councelor Stringer and councelor
gold that I think we do need a condition
of drainage on that site to just make
sure things are being done properly and
that there's no there's nothing getting
into the environment that shouldn't be
there thank you very much thank you um
before I make some points Brun on the
enforcement actions Etc I thought you
said earlier on that they've all been
concluded is that the case or is there
something still going
on sorry could you just repeat the
question chair enforcement actions such
as pollution B hole and everything else
I thought you said in your uh
presentation that there's no outstanding
enforcement actions at the moment is
that true uh if I just clarify it there
are no live enforcement notices on the
site so no enforcement notices in force
there are several PCN planning
contention notices that have been served
which ask questions that um when we have
an allegation and we investigate we want
to know more we go to the um occupier
and we or owner or whoever's responsible
and say tell us this information we do
that in the PCN so there are several
PCN that are still being um dealt with
but no live notices in force thank you
um so my points um it's as shamed that
the agent or the owner isn't present
actually because they got lots of
questions that perhaps they can only
answer and one of them was has been
alluded to before is about the occupancy
um Holiday Homes but you can actually
stay well they can be occupied for 11
months of the year one month vacated and
I just want to ask um whether the
residents know that and how they enforce
it locally but it's outside of this in
some respects um the pcns Etc of course
if you get a resident refuses to leave
well is that the owner's fault or the
resident so is that another side to it
actually the owner's got very little
control over it apart from bringing in
some action which they've obviously done
all the council's done so I don't say
that's a big thing I get a bit about
supporting the local community um in a
way the whole complex there provides a
service to some people it be a
restaurant Cafe um hot tub experience
whatever there's business there that
definitely benefits from having more
people there more people visiting so
that's good um we need to support those
rural communities and businesses in the
rural areas I think this does um and
also rural tourism and we talk about
sustainability don't forget that for
Rural tourism you only have to low
locational sustainability so again not a
massive thing it's slightly different to
development in lots of respects
um I'm really I mean looking at I mean
Council War boys you talked about not
being sustainable as in the way they're
designed carbon neutral we don't know
that they're not using or won't use in
the future solar panels to provide
electricity for those Caravans or even
an oilbased system or ground we don't
know uh we can only see what it is right
now and there five Caravans when you
look at the area in which it's going
it's a natural place to put five
Caravans I do believe it's an infill um
there's a road there and actually the
area is already partitioned off so it
doesn't affect the loss of agricultural
land as it's partitioned off with with
with soft planting anyway so it looks if
you to look down on that plan that's the
ideal to put place to put five Caravans
and business you don't build things or
buy things or get extra assets unless
you think you can make money out of it
so to say that we don't think there's a
need for these five Caravans well we're
not the businessmen they are and it's
their business and if they feel there's
a need for five more and they can offset
the cost by by rent they they're good on
them and also if it brings in people
like H Seasons or other people people
that would develop that site even
further um then that's great for us
isn't it it's great for mids it's great
for the local people and the local
communities um I don't see that affects
the um the the view of this place any
different it's five Caravans amongst a
load of Caravans it is what it is um
they're not going to make any difference
whatsoever in the way I look at it um I
mean I'm going to let go around debate
once more I think it's it's deserving of
it but at the moment it to me it's
pretty much all positives although do
get the point about the drainage and um
and obviously the um the sewage side of
life I think that's important so we'll
go around once again so let's start you
councilor War
boys again I think I think thank you
chairman uh again I think I i' there's
some my assum as this is it's a full
planning permission so it is possible to
attach condition
uh to ex to uh awarding um permission to
develop it is only five more Caravans so
the I think the impact on the
um on the commercial side is isn't going
to be sort of terribly significant
though I do agree with supporting rural
Industries and attracting tourists to
the area I think one of
the
ways in which to attract people to the
area is to make it an attractive place
to
visit um and as and in lots of ways a
safe and secure place to visit I think
we have a responsibility it is within
the national planning framework I'm not
sure how much that applies to Caravans
but we do have a responsibility to
achieve well designed
places and that's a design in terms of
its infrastructure the robustness of its
drainage its electricity
Supply um I think the sustainability in
term of its um carbon impact is an is
now a much more
significant um thing to take into
account in
2015 we didn't have a hadn't declared a
climate emergency things have progressed
since then and I think Landscaping I
think that would actually sort of
mitigate some of the concerns of the
parish councils I think it would also
make it a more attractive place to visit
um so in in a way it is actually supp by
putting in a condition about
landscaping and we will actually sort of
enhance the business plan attract people
it is supporting local the local
industry the tourist industry that the
the site is on a brown route it is on a
major tourist route through suffk it is
something that tourists to other parts
of suffk will pass and as and we have a
responsibility to make that or to try
and ensure that's as attractive as
possible so I have got reservations
about this
application sorry Council W boys thank
you Council Stringer
please yeah thank you chair um yeah at
first glance you think well another five
you know what difference does that make
in the grand scheme of things uh but
when you go back to the master
plan uh I I can't it's a difficult one
because the master plan actually hasn't
been built in the way the master plan
shows on the document although you
shouldn't look at other documents but if
I see something that says final master
plan uh I look at it uh and in fact that
final master plan doesn't even show the
road that we're looking at through here
so but but also the final master plan
makes no reference to where they treat
sewage here
anywhere um and I have to still say if
there's a little tick box that says it's
connected to a main sewer fine not got a
problem if you're relying on private
treatment works here multiple private
treatment works you need that response
from the technical people involved which
is our own building regulations team to
say this can be achieved you may be
approving 5 Karat and slap on top of the
biod disk plants that exist at the
moment I don't know I haven't got a plan
so uh you know what and that wouldn't
encourage economic growth if the sewage
system here fails all of the investment
here Hy and say will go down the toilet
or not you know that's the whole point
sometimes all of those that people that
are investing you sometimes have to
slightly not save them from themselves
but that's the whole point of planning
we plan where this stuff goes so we
avoid a disaster so what I'm suggesting
here is I can't approve any more
Caravans here until I see that they can
be built into a sustainable drainage
system that includes
effluent equally I think if we are going
to approve the five here you need to
really uh upscale that that planting
because it it does look a bit of a sod
from the road I have to say uh although
according to the master plan you'll be
seeing solar panels along the road as
well the 200 kilow are they installed
yet uh but I say at the moment I'm
really uncomfortable with this we can we
can condition the landscape but for me I
need to see the drainage before I
approve any more here thank you CH okay
yeah I get your point maybe bring that
as condition so um we'll come back to
that um I will bring in U Mr pman G you
might be able to cover up cover a couple
of the points you've
raised yes um I'm sorry about this uh my
technology this side of things isn't
doing too well today um just do ask
actually I know this is a bizarre way of
doing it but um can I just ask bonwin in
terms of the permission for the rest of
the site can we um and I'm doing this
for the purposes of an inquiry I've got
um just confirm two things one I
understand there is a sustainability
drainage um ation strategy that went
with that and so details of sustainable
Urban drainage but that would have only
covered surface water drainage and that
was that was part of the larger scheme
um and I presume that is um either in
place or going to be put in place given
the conditions on on the original
consent that's one thing I don't know if
you are you happy to do you know
anything about that bman can you add any
more to that point yeah I can reply to
that those conditions have been removed
from that planning permission because um
after the grant of that planning
permission and discussions between the
agent and the lead local flood Authority
suffer County Council it was found that
it wasn't necessary um and it wasn't
practicable so they applied to remove
those conditions and they were removed
last year okay thank you that's very
helpful and the other uh point I was
just going to get into is can you for
the and I'm asking you to do this for
the sake of can you just confirm the uh
current tourism condition that is in
place with regard to the remaining site
in terms of its wording of uh 11 months
uh occupancy or do you have the exact
wording of that available yep I do I'll
just read it out because I I I'm I just
want to make sure that it's very clear
and for a matter of record what is
conditioned for the rest of the site
okay so the condition is entitled
specific restriction upon use break
period for lodges/ Statics and it says
the static Caravans hereby approved and
the holiday lodges hereby approved shall
not be occupied at all or used as
holiday accommodation between 31st of
December and 1st of February inclusive
in any calendar year there are obviously
some
semantic improvements that could be made
to that but I am for the sake of
consistency of decision- making my
recommendation is that we impose that
same condition
although members are free to make
suggestions to improve it and that would
allow somebody who is holidaying as long
as they are participating in the
residence as a on a holiday to uh be in
that unit or the the units proposed for
up to 11
months that's correct so members may
recall AAL decisions from a couple of
years ago in which the councils used to
impose conditions on holiday occupant
for a 30-day stay no reoccupation within
30 days um but that that approach has
been undermined by appeal decisions and
so general practice at the moment is now
to go with this uh specifying a holiday
use so there is an implied um use in the
term holiday as opposed to a a principal
dwelling um your main residence your
holiday residence being two separate
things um and then yeah so the break
Clause of the one month allowing
technically allowing holidays for up to
11 months yes and but ultimately as long
as they are using the accommodation for
Holiday use not the main or sole
residents and I just wanted to clarify
that and that is what is being applied
to this proposal before us yep The
Proposal is is holiday holiday is in the
description of the proposed development
and it is within now gift to clarify the
condition restricting the use so that
it's holiday we could also include and
not as a so or main residents which is
often what we do for other occupancy
restrictions like agricultural workers
and things like that um if if members
wanted to add to the previous condition
to make it
clearer that would be perhaps useful to
do that if I may suggest uh
chairman yeah no I I absolutely agree
and um absolutely I mean I'd love to
have an 11 month holiday unfor I've
never had one um but I totally agree
with you and that that would need to be
conditioned I think so can you think
about that John
and condition thank you sorry to do that
I just needed to do add of those couple
of points I apologize for interceding at
that point no it's really useful thank
you okay uh where were we uh Council
Norris I
think thank you uh I've listened to the
debate however I still have too many
concerns regarding localized
infrastructure issues such as F water
disposal electricity outages and
flooding uh I'm afraid I'm still not
able to support this application thank
you councelor melon
please yeah thank you chair um yeah I
was just been looking through the 24 um
conditions on the previous uh applic
um from
2015 and it's it's number nine which is
the the details of the sustainable Urban
drainage system which apparently is now
being knocked on the head anyway so
there's nothing in there about foul
drainage um it I would be much more
comfortable about this application if
there was a condition that that talked
about that I don't know if that can be
uh added yeah I I think it can and uh
again Mr Payton is probably working
really hard in the background trying to
come condition but I think that'd be a
really useful one and a very important
Point are they all your
[Music]
questions yes thank you chair okay counc
gold I think nothing to add to what uh
to what's been said what I've said
previously and what others have said um
I think the the condition we've been
talking about is is key to being able to
agree
this thank you councelor Casten please
thank you um I think um what councils
have said about the issues with um
carbon and um the climate emergency I
think um there's going to be a huge
offset in the fact that people will be
going to um holiday in in in suffk
instead of traveling vast distances in
cars or on cheap flights abroad and um
we that will more than offset any um
issues with the building of these um
Caravans um the um conditions of um
drainage I think will um only cover
these five dwellings these five Caravans
so we we I don't know if we're solving
existing problems with that but I do
think that that's important for these
ones um I um I at this point I'd
probably um like to um
propose
approval of this um with the extra
conditions of the foul drainage and um
the and the um holidays not being the
holid being a holiday um residence and
not a um a soul residence um or whatever
those those words were that um Brun said
earlier um so could I could I propose
that please
uh yes you can the the only conditioning
has to be for these F everybody's clear
with this we're looking at it's
application for five it's not about the
whole sites it's these five uh buildings
that we're actually dealing with and
therefore um any condition has to be for
these five ear is is everybody happy
with
that good and sorry yeah go on sorry I'm
buttered in there uh could could I I
think it's very important to get the
robustness of the uh foul water
infrastructure really nailed down but I
also think landscap i' I'd be happy to
support it I think if Landscaping was
also incorporated into the motion
because I think it is important to make
these sites look as visually attractive
as possible in order to
attract tourists to our lovely
Countryside yeah I I I agree with you
thank you for coming in on that um so
we're going to break in a minute while
we go for so Mr pton G can sort of just
look at some conditions but um going
back to a couple of things that brought
up one was flooding I don't think this
would cause any flooding whatsoever um
and in fact it sits in flood level one I
think it is so there's no issue with
that um electricity that stands to Lo
authority to be honest with you um and
again all conditions will only be for
these five uh for these five buildings
I'm just going to bring Mr Payton G in
just for a second um so you can just Sor
thank you um thank you again um sorry I
wasn't quite sure if there has been a
proposal passed or not I'll leave that
with Rob and uh I to determine but if
that was uh put forward you at the
moment we've got two in addition to the
recommendation before members we've got
um a condition on drainage so not
withstanding the details of drainage
that has been submitted that your
officers will seek to agree uh all
drainage details and I would imagine we
would need to look at whether they are
sustainable as a part of that uh
consideration um I wouldn't want to add
too much specific wording on that
because I think we need to be open to
what may come forward uh for us to look
at as a separate matter of the discharge
of condition in terms of the condition
on uh use of the uh uh lodges um what
I'm just saying to members is that we
already have a a proposal in front of us
for a condition on the use of The Lodges
what we are just going to clarify within
the wording of that uh condition is that
it shall not be the sole use uh of the
occupier or their main residence that is
all um I haven't got anything more to
add apart from if we go into
Landscaping um I don't know if Bon is
able to put the uh Red Line plan back up
on screen but um given the uh indicative
plan that was part of that um the
Landscaping will only at the moment
we've got mostly control over the red
line area what kind of landscaping are
we talking about here because we're
going to be possibly not fitting it in
within the space we have available
within the redline plan I don't know
what the expectations are in respect to
members um and I appreciate the land
around it is owned by the owner and we
have and we are able to condition
conditions that apply to the blue line
if you like the the air area also owned
by the owner but there is a degree of
risk in respect of doing that um and
that risk especially is if there are
other planned uses um possibly for that
area that this Landscaping would
interfere with and that may not be
acceptable to the owner uh if we were to
do that so um there is risk around
landscaping and I'm just trying to
explore to what extent Landscaping is an
issue here and to what extent of
landscaping is being sought um you got
the red line plan on screen if you were
oh for some reason I can't see it that's
helpful here we go if if you can just go
down a couple of slides uh bonwin to the
that one uh yep lout thank you so we we
have um you might have to point these
out with a cursor indicatively five
lodges uh
shown now if we're dealing with
screening to the rear of these along
that boundary line say a hedge then okay
that we can we can seek that if we're
talking about something far more
significant
um then I think we we we've got a risk
that we need to look
at Mr chairman might I um just speak on
that please D um yeah I'm I'm quite
happy to accept an amendment to The
Proposal but I think um we should really
be concentrating on the Hedge that we
just spoke about the the one behind
these Caravans and maybe that the um
you've got to be a bit careful with
these things because you you give them a
a um a minimum height and they use it as
a Target when you might have had a
higher one but I think if they could
cover
three4 of the height of the buildings
and no less I think that would make a
big difference to the visual aspect the
the visual um damage that that would do
across that
field your points
please
Bron you there you got your hand
up sorry I'm talking and I'm I'm muted
um yes just a couple of practical points
we don't have a blue line plan here so
we don't know how much land to the north
and west the um applicant controls so
whether it's just the red line the
extent of planting that we could achieve
would be pretty limited with the
Caravans on site I can go back and find
out I understand that they potentially
do own a bit more
um so it might be something that's
possible to to control if we have a blue
line plan but we don't currently have
that at the moment the other thing um I
was going to say was in the photograph I
was showing that there is some planting
some um immature planting already
showing in the photograph along the
boundaries um so it may well be that if
we condition it you just get details of
what's already in there and I would have
to go back and double check if that's
something that we've already agreed as a
condition on a previous permission for
the site it's possible that that's the
case and there was something else and I
can't
remember no
problem that's can I can I summarize
that slightly then in in the context of
what we have before us we are dealing
with the redline plan only we therefore
think that the any Landscaping sort is
probably going to be limited at this
point if we were to deal with it today
uh for essentially a hedge maybe a
native hedge around around the outer
boundary of that Redline plan uh to the
North and East Boundary anything more
than that if that is the expectation of
uh members we would either need to go
away and find out more information or
that may be an issue that it can't be
achieved okay thank you thank you okay
so I think we've been around the mill
now um everybody's had a chance to
debate this ask the questions as
required do we have a seconder to the
proposal we do have a proposal from
councilor
Caston
give you a couple of
minutes okay um I will good uh Council
gold yes just say I I will um uh second
The Proposal thank you thank you good so
we have a proposal in a second there
will be conditions I'll talk about those
in a moment but summ summarize for
myself um I think that this does support
the rural um business areas I think it'd
be fantastic if some all that H Seasons
came in there it would improve the site
without a shadow of a doubt the company
like that um this is five Caravans after
all that's all we're looking at on an
already established site um I understand
the need for conditions for drainage and
I think it's important for these five
properties only uh the landscaping
that's um could be a bit of an issue it
might just be soft planting or hedging
or a tree um but at the end of the day
this is five extra Bungalows we're in a
mass of bungal it's already visual from
the from the uh from the road and uh as
on page4 paragraph 6.4 it discusses that
and um it RS the visual impact of the
extension will be homologized as part of
the wider complex and I think that's
correct
um I think there's lots of benefits to
this uh to be honest with it's already
an established site um therefore I I
will almost certainly be moving for
approval um with that in mind we have
proposed here we have a second there can
we we just read out conditions again
please John so we know what we're
actually going to vote
on my apologies um my system is not
again doing very well today so I at the
moment I've got we've got the so the
recommendation before members is the
standard time condition uh approved
plans and documents and restriction on
holiday occupancy of Caravans the same
as the uh permission of 3150 strike 15
but with the addition of uh saying that
it's uh not to be used for sole
residents um and then we have uh further
to that uh a condition for drainage
notwithstanding the details that
submitted to be agreed by your officers
and I missed a bit about whether
Landscaping was added or not I do
apologize was a landscaping scheme to be
agreed added we like it investigated
because um as you said it's it's quite a
difficult one to do and um Landscaping
can be everything from a a sort of big
lump of Earth to a couple of trees so in
that case and I will just simply put it
as Landscaping to be agreed which would
mean we would apply our standard
Landscaping condition then they have to
come in with us with the details and we
will agree it to our satisfaction yes
okay um you've heard the proposal we do
have a proposed we do have a second a
therefore we'll take a vote Mr
Carmichael if you'd like to record the
vote
please and I just like to um if you
carry on with the vote thank you chair
so if you could please respond with for
against or abstain councelor caraston
for councelor gold
four councelor Humphries
four councelor
melon
for councel Norris
against councelor
Stringer to at what point do I get to to
speak against the
motion apologies councelor um chair what
do you want to do in the situation do
you want to hear from councelor string
or do you want me to carry on with the
vote I think we had enough debate I've
got to be honest with you and then we
had a proposed in a second it um I think
legally we just carry on with the vote
do we not and correct me if I'm wrong
well I think yes we have started the
vote it would be it wouldn't be totally
forbidden it might be a bit irregular
too but I
mean are you with me on that Mr carich I
think so um Mr um because we have had
two rounds of debate on that point as
long as you're comfortable chair yeah I
comfortable I think actually councelor
Stringer you had your point in debate
really and you could have actually moved
against this so you got your now it's
yes or no I'm I'm sorry chair I was
waiting to hear what the motion was
going to be and what conditions you were
putting on
because there was other information
about private treatment works and sewage
that I now have uh that might be
relevant to you now now I've heard your
proposal and your conditions I believe
the conditions aren't
enough but if you're happy to make the
decision without that knowledge that's
fine but I don't think that's very
regular and a good way of Mr depre
please I think I think the vote has been
called right um rightly or wrongly and
we're at us I think chairman you have
you hav't an element of discretion it
would be a bit irregular you but I think
you're indicating you're choosing to
continue with the vote and I think that
that is um
lawful yeah I think it's lawful um I
also believe In fairness and um I also
believe that people mistake make
mistakes if I've made a mistake I
apologize I don't think I have though
councelor Stringer will Council a vote
Mr Carmichael will we come back to the
vote still have proposal still have a s
there councel Stringer your comment yeah
I just wanted to make the comment that
the I've just checked out the maximum
size of private treatment works you can
get is for 30 people and they all have
to have an individual drain they can't
share a drain so at the moment if this
site is up to building rigs there'll be
25 separate treatment plants on this
site so the issue of where the sewage is
going to go is actually vital so there
must be a condition that this has its
own treatment work cancer Stringer I
don't think added anything to it because
they're already putting in a condition
to look at drainage what more can we do
so Mr car Michael we'll start V
again thank you chair so just to confirm
on that so we the the previous vote is
abandoned yeah um and we will start
again um without prejudice on this point
so councelor James Caston
for councelor Peter gold for
councelor Barry Humphries
four councelor Andrew melon
four councelor Mike
Norris sorry slow and unmuting uh
against against thank you um counc
Andrew Stringer
against and councelor Roland War boys
four thank you chair I make that five
votes to two Mr can you confirm I agree
five votes to two the resolution has
been passed thank you thank you um thank
you for your uh contribution good debate
uh very good questioning like I say it's
a real shame that the um the ear wasn't
there to answer many of our questions
but that's the way it is so thank you
I'll now hand over the chair to
councelor Guthrie but first we'll have a
five minute break um Mr car Michael if
we can have five minutes
please uh well actually I think we need
a bit longer than five minutes don't we
because I think some people might need
to have some food for
um you're now the chair it's entirely up
to you can can we have a 20 minute break
is 20 minutes sufficient for
everybody I Madam chairman I have we got
I I think it it seems like a good idea
to have a vote though it's not for me to
have sorry to have an adjournment not
for me to say but well I don't think
we've got any public speakers for the
third item have we no we we haven't
apart from the Ward member Mr from the
member indeed so it's it's yes it's up
to you if you think that yes well would
would members like a 20 minute
break or do they want to cut it shorter
to 15 I mean all speak up I'll let you
all speak up say what you want I'm happy
to carry on happy to car happy to carry
on happyself five minutes and
then okay let's go for five let's go for
five minutes and keep going yeah yeah
five minutes thank you thank you
Robert
right chair we are now live again I'm
back is that counselor
Stringer yep oh hello I recognize the
dlit
tones right chair so I could just
confirm so councelor carsten Robert
Robert will take a roll call just to
make sure we're all here I'm sure when
he's back sorry I had myself on mute
shair that was rather
embarrassing um apologies there um
that's all right if I just do a roll
call and we'll um just make sure
everyone's back so councelor Kasten
presid councelor gold pres councelor
Guthrie pres councel Humphries pres
councel melon president councel Norris
president councelor
Stringer we've already heard know there
sorry councelor and Council of War boys
president and the Ward member councelor
Pratt present brilliant thank you chair
we are all
here start again oh we
are we are live chair sorry the all of
that part we were red beg your pardon
everybody well welcome back and thank
you very much for coming back so soon uh
so we now move on to the final match of
the agenda on the paper papers 1 195
agenda item c um battisford and ringa
and we have the ward member councelor
Pratt and the case officer is Daniel
Cameron if you'd like to present the
case for us please thank you very much
thank you
chair here we go is that up for
everybody can everybody
see yep that's fine yeah okay um so what
we've got before us is an application
for change of use of
land this is the site here um seen
aerially the road running sort of um
diagonally across as
b178 we've got great bryett off to the
west and then we've got an angling water
um projecty watering um immediate to
South and then we've got some immediate
um to the immediate South we've got four
semi- detached dwellings
there uh in The Wider context we've got
watch a base off to the north North and
then surrounding we've got strongly
agricultural character so in terms of
the site location plan we're looking at
the red area which contains an access up
onto the B
1078 um the the ownership of the land
also extends to the blue land I'll
quickly go into what's going on
there um we've got some adjacent housing
sites um together for a total of nine
dwellings we've got one application for
four dwellings here that was approved
under outline dc18 0544
7 and then immediately adjacent to the
road we've got dc1804 774 and that's a
five
units
and if we just have a quick look at the
constraints map we're flood zone one and
we've also got the roadways marked in
blue um we've got public right of way
Network and the dotted green lines and
then we've got uh a grade one and grade
two listed buildings off in great Bryer
themselves um so i' said previously it's
for a temporary change of use of land um
previously the the site had a barn
stable um on it that was for use in
conjunction with the blue land which
were used as paddocks um so any change
of use that we might want to agree here
on a temporary basis at the end of that
temporary basis would revert back to the
previous planning use of equestrian use
as part of that we've got no change to
the building and these site photos from
the public foot path running along the
rear of the site you can see the barn in
place with the uh shuted door
there you can also see the uh
relationship to the houses up on on the
top the site slopes away from the road
there here we've got the view of the
site across um from the B 1078 you can
see the Red Roof of the B quite clearly
um and the trees at the
rear this is again from the B 1078
closer to the houses you can see the
track as it
was and then as we move forward this is
from the most recent site visit so we've
got some fencing erected around the barn
itself pardon me Members my throat went
a bit dry there and we've got
some addition traffic coming up and down
the access route this is a closer um
view of fencing in the
barn and then this is a return
view up towards the um the residential
dwellings we've got the um existing
hedging in
place if
I jump backwards in the report
members
now just want to um bring to members
attention something that might be
confusing within the report we've got
additional comments from the parish
council and from our environmental
health teams um that's due to a change
in the description of development as the
application went on and we thought it
prudent to get additional comments from
both um so previously we have been
looking at temporary change of use for
the site as a builder's yard in line
with the adjacent um Housing
Development with then a subsequent
change of use for the bar
afterwards um there was some confusion
in to what exactly the bond will become
afterwards and given the level of
confusion it was causing and and the
distress it was likely causing for the
parish and for the members that's been
removed from the application such we're
only dealing with a temporary change of
use so there'd be no change to the
existing appearance of the site um and
it's worth noting as well in the report
that similar development could be
brought on site via permitted
development we've got
planning permission granted for nine
units on the fields adjacent um normal
practice if if you didn't have a a
building adjacent that could be readily
converted you'd pick a corner of the
site bring some portter cabins on there
and that would be your site compound for
the duration of the um of the
development key issues explored within
the report are the impacts of the likely
use on the residential amenity um issues
created through um pollution associated
with the proposed use and what controls
we might be able to implement within
that um hence at the end of the report
members um you'll see that rather than a
bullet pointed list of conditions we've
got fully typed out conditions for you
there um those are drafted in accordance
with the comments of the parish council
um and our environmental health Team
such that we can have some confidence
that there shouldn't be any adverse
impacts um
on the the neighboring residential
amenity while use it in place at which
point once the development has ceased
the previous use of equester use comes
back into action and then the applicant
is free to make another application once
they're in a better position to decide
whether they want to retain the site or
dispose of
it therefore members you'll see from the
report that the proposed recommendation
is to approve the temporary change inter
use thank you very much for that um do
members have any questions um we'll go
through the list uh for the planning
officer and we can start with uh
councelor War
boys um just just I I think the
conditions are evidently sensible and uh
required I just question the original
planning application for usus as of
stables to get because of the associated
Paddock uh The Paddock will no
longer exist as a paddock it will be
house
Gardens so H um so how would that affect
the the the barn it would be no
longer required as a stables or feed
because there' be no Paddock for horses
no so the paddock use would would would
go that's gone now we have planning
permission securing the the residential
use of the land um in terms of the end
of the temporary use period the the the
barn would no longer be able to be used
as a builder's yard it would have to go
back to its previous defined planning
use which is
equestrian so we are in an agricultural
area there may be
um there may be others within the area
who have other land for grazing of
horses and might want to make use of the
Stables but I think probably at that
point there would be a decision for the
owner to make whether or not that was
likely to be a viable use for the barn
whether they wanted to rent it out
whether they wanted to utilize it
themselves um obviously you're right the
horses would have to be taken to graze
elsewhere um actually Daniel I mean I
think you've answered it quite well
because that's for the another time
we're not using that but it was a good
point for Council of War boys to bring
up so councelor warboys do you have
another question no that's fine thank
you just thank you councelor
Stringer yeah I think my question's been
asked it's more about the access come
the end of it you know if you've got two
class uses using the same access uh but
I think that was covered during that
previous okay we can always debate that
a little more if you like later
councelor Norris any questions for the
officer no questions thank you councelor
melon no questions councelor Humphries
no questions thank you councelor gold no
questions thanks councelor Casten just a
small one Madam chairman um does the
building have a Personnel door or is it
just a roller shutter
door can uh
sorry members I thought I was unmuted
but double click again um I I'm just
double- checking the plans for you
counselor um with regards to a Personnel
door I think it is the roller shutter
but I think the existing drawings do
show an
additional I mean if it was used for
horses they'd have stable doors in
inside
obviously yeah no just going back off
the existing drawings it is the
shuttered
door okay thank you very
much um and then there's myself um just
going back to um slide 15 um just for
confirmation I presume the muddy bit on
the side is still is in the applicant's
ownership yes chair I'm just seeing if I
can get the
um the reant plan up for you again it
was a photograph I think actually
yes I shouldn't worry too much about it
other than yes it is no yes it is it is
yeah if I if I can get there quickly but
no I think I am yeah okay
technology right um
so moving on um public speakers we don't
have any speakers from the parish
council object to supporter or applicant
so um if we can now move to the ward
member councelor Daniel Pratt if you'd
like to tell us about this application
site please sure absolutely yes so um
this this um application has moved on a
very very long way since um I put in the
original request for this to be
considered by the planning committee and
the original concerns were based on the
long-term environmental issues that
would arise from the use of the stables
for a light industrial or commercial
unit and the impact this would have on
the amenity use of the surrounding uh
residential area um there was also a
large concern with regard to the
ambiguity of the proposed use of the
site in the original um application the
the the full planning application now
being considered as a change of use uh
of the site uh as a builder's yard as we
all know in conjunction with the
adjacent development site and the view
of many residents particularly those
living adjacent and nearby the site is
that the temporary use of a barn as a
builder's yard would now be accept an
acceptable temporary resolution um for
the expediency of the development um
those residents um and members of Parish
Council have also welcomed the planning
recommendations particularly the
recommendation to Grant a temporary
change of use um as a builder's yard for
a period not exceeding 2 years or once
the building work are completed
whichever comes sooner um however there
are still um some points of exist
existential concerns that we could raise
um that are both new and
historical and these include but are not
limited to the fact that the barn was
originally built without planning
permission and the applicant had a
history of non-compliance to the
planning conditions and enforcement
previously so there are concerns whether
uh this use will truly be temporary if
if the site did become permanent large
Vehicles would continue to have uh
access and there would be difficulty for
the new residents accessing this site
and it could also create hazards on the
highway whilst they do so um this
includes uh Vehicles parking on and
blocking driveways to the adjacent
houses on little Hill um a permanent
Builder's yard is also not conducive to
the surrounding residential amenity I
think um the the current proposal does
little to allay the anxieties that this
will just become a permanent Builder's
yard used for storing large machinery
and equipment to serve other
construction sites in the area um the
recommendations could go further to
reduce this
uncertainty over how the barn will be
used in the future perhaps um what we
need what our residents really need is
the is reassurance that they will not be
subjected to unacceptable harm arising
from traffic issues overlooking or loss
of PR privacy um and nuisances from dust
noise and fumes um there's also a
conflict of interest in in a way because
there's adjacent to this site is a bed
and breakfast which is dependent on the
Tranquility that the current setting has
to offer um one one um recommendation
put forward by the parish council um is
that it could be used as residential uh
development a recent survey was
undertaken by the parish council and
showed that 27 hour 28 residents would
prefer to see the site used for
residential purposes as opposed to be
continued to use as a builder yard or a
commercial unit so if possible I would
like to request that the committee
considers not only agreeing to the
planning recommendations set out but to
consider further conditions or caveats
possible to block a consecutive
application for change as a bu Builder
yard and recommend future use for
residential
development thank you for that um I
think if um the planning officer wants
to come in on that I don't think you can
actually stipulate that at this point
because we are just looking at the
application as is but I can be um
corrected on that um before we move to
questions to your goodself can we just
have some confirmation uh from the
planning officer and also I've made a
note here what can mids do to ensure
that it does not um uh go over its
allocated time as a builder's yard
please before we get to questions to
council so with regard to Future uses
we'd need to have a a further planning
application yeah made on on that basis
we'd then be able to look at the the
planning merits and and the key issues
that would arise from any use associated
in that in that application um in terms
of
um the the condition for for the time
limit um
so we we've written that in such a way
that they have two years following the
date of Grant of the permission
um or at the point at which the
adjoining housing developments approved
under dc18 refs um are completed for all
practical purposes whichever is the
earliest so we would need to be
um well we would have the time quite
clearly for the two years and we'd be
able to monitor completions through
building RS um
completions um so that we can then be
sure as to whatever is the earliest I
mean we do have a need to be reasonable
in terms of how quickly the site returns
to its equestrian use if you have large
pieces of Machinery or or leftover Goods
on site so we have try to um incorporate
that within that condition giving them a
period of time 28 Days Grace from um the
termination of of the of the use in
which to remove the material equipment
or hard Landscaping resulting from the
uses AB Builder yard I mean we all know
that when um applications come in again
or enforcements are involved it's always
said well apply for it and regularize it
so uh what we want to do is make sure
that that doesn't happen that it is
finished as is when finished can can we
have assurances on that I think I think
in terms of our planning policies we are
quite clear on temporary uses that where
we're granting them we'd either want
then be followed up with a a full
planning permission for that permanent
use to be enacted or we'd want to see
that use ceased
um I think we probably need to be in a
position where we have some fairly
compelling reasons why we would want to
allow that temporary use to
continue um but our our policy position
is that if we've granted a temporary use
once that's it you've had your temporary
use and it should now be moved on to E
either a full planning
application or
um rted back to its previous planning
use right right so now um can we come
back apologies to you councelor Pratt
but I just felt that we needed to sort
of bottom out your um issue there um
yeah thank you um so any questions uh
for the ward member councilor War
boys no no questions councelor
Stringer no questions thank you
councelor Norris no questions thank you
councelor
Malon uh no questions thank you
Dan counc
humph no questions mam chair councelor
gold no questions thank you councelor
Caston no questions thank you and I sort
of rather jumped in at the beginning
thinking you were all going to ask
questions so there we are um right well
thank you for that uh councelor Pratt so
I think we can open up to the debate so
we'll go round um and my next order on
this piece of paper is councelor Casten
if you'd like to open us up on this one
please thank you very much Madam
chairman um yeah I don't have any big
issues with this um proposal it's three
years it's some temporary um I if it was
going for a permanent um change of use I
think it would be a good idea to put a
Personnel door on the side so that at
8:00 on a Saturday morning you don't
have to open a noisy roller shutter door
to access just to gain access um to um
with without bringing machines in but um
I don't know if if other members thought
that that was a particularly good idea I
think um I I'd propose that but I I can
understand for a three-year temporary
it's it's probably a bit much to ask so
um yeah I've don't see a huge problem in
it and um yeah I'll listen to further
debate thank you thank you councelor Kon
that's a very good and useful Point
actually I'm sure it wouldn't take too
much to bang a in it um but um can we
just clear it's two years we're going
for I think isn't it um
Daniel yes two years in line with the
parish
council not such an unreasonable request
so maybe members as they go through the
debate they might like that thank you
for that councelor Casten right next
person is councelor humph
please councelor gold first Madam chair
on my list it says councelor humph all
right I should say I take advantage of
it then thank you very much um so um
yeah I mean Council perhaps talking
about other things uh that people are
opposed to and everything else yet the
parish council basically supports
application maximum two two years the
completion what's the debate and uh on
the other side of it of course you've
got the security of equipment in the
rural area with the increase in rural
crime what 8.1 million now this is a
really critical time to secure stuff so
this ticks every box and of course the
other thing it reduces the carbon
footprint because there isn't so far for
this Machinery to travel to the worksite
across the road so it ticks every box
from environmental to security and it
has the uh has the um approval of the
great briset Parish Council so yeah I
move to
approve well hang on a minute we've got
to go through made I'm just saying I'm
moved towards it oh I beg your pardon
yes as in will be yes okay thank you um
councelor gold I do apologize but you
weren't on my list so here we go
councelor gold no no ways at all um I I
have a little difficulty with this and
I'm I'm comforted by what uh Council
Pratt had to tell us about the uh local
response to the changed application so
um compared to what else the other
business we've been doing today this
seems mercifully uh straightforward
thank you thank you for that councelor
melon yes thank you chair
um yes I mean clearly as um councelor
Pratt said that you know things have
moved on since he did the calling and
negotiation has gone on with the between
the officers and the applicant um in
order to um come up with these um these
conditions which seem eminently sensible
to me um I I do have some concerns about
whether they're
actually enforcable I don't know I don't
think any of our enforcements staff are
going to be standing at the end of the
road checking which vehicles go in and
out but um so as usual we're dependent
on the on on the public for um to as our
eyes and ears um yes I mean I Echo
Council hre's uh you know support for
locking stuff away at the moment there
does seem to be a huge amount of rural
crime going on um so if you can you know
put your JCB in a barn that's got to be
a lot safer than leaving it out on a
site so um potentially it could make the
whole the whole operation a lot more
tidy um you know we we have to deal with
what's in front of us which is an
application to change the use
temporarily that seems to be sensible to
me um what happens after that is for
another day so um yes I'm minded to
approve this good thank you very much
for your comments councelor Norris uh
thank you yes um I'm quite uh happy to
go along with the recommendation on this
and the quite R conditions that we have
uh on this application so that's all I
have to say thank you thank you
councelor Norris counselor
Stringer yes chair happy to see that
there's been some negotiation and local
voices have been heard just want a
little bit of clarification uh physical
delivery 45 ft Lorry with a high AB on
it turns up with a load of bricks they
high AB them off and I take it they will
teleport of them down the track into the
barn if they want to store them away
we're not talking about 45 foot lorries
accessing This Barn are we because if we
are that's a huge incline and you'll get
them stuck so I just wanted to know you
do we want to preclude that or if
they're going to bring Lor's on site
there's nowhere for them to turn so you
know we I just let that clarified
really Tel can you make some sort of
comments I've seen people reversing up
and um one almost thinks counselor
Stringer that's
the issue of the applicant but uh can
can can Daniel give us a hand yeah no I
mean in terms of of the use of the
access highways were fairly relaxed um
but in terms of um probably where we are
um we we have asked for for condition to
be added so that within um three months
of the the date of Grant of the change
of use we have details of the size and
type of vehicle able to access a site um
we've put a condition on there at all
times Vehicles accessing or egressing a
site must be able to do so in a forward
gearing um and and the the detail of
vehicle condition requires that any
vehicle accessing the site not of the
specified type or size um can't make um
delivery
there does that answer your question
counselor Stringer uh no not really uh
because it's it's the amount of
engineering required to make that
incline of
accessible U you know that's massive
amounts of engineering for a temporary
drop off I was I was just assuming
there'll be a Telly Handler buzzing up
and down that lane all day uh you know
taking in the deliveries rather than
trying to make this this this track
accessible to thumping great hgvs no no
no that's not the intention of the of
the condition I apologize for the
confusion no I I I think probably yeah
as as count the string of points out yet
probably likely that there is something
up and down taking taking the large
deliveries what we want want to um avoid
is those large Vehicles accessing the
site you know it might be feasible for
works manans or or or smaller Goods
vehicles to access the site that's what
we want detail of and we want to prevent
large vehicles from being able to access
that that access down to the the
Builder's yard at all that's exactly
what I wanted to hear thank you thank
you for that
um uh where are we councelor War boys
please uh yes I think there's been some
good positive discussions between the
applicant and the officers and the
parish council's voice has been listen
to I think it's a quite a
sensible uh
proposal um I think the the um concerns
about
lighting uh and use I think councilor
kton had a very good Caston had a very
good uh proposal that the applicant
might take into account having a small
door for those times who just wants to
pop pop in and out but fine thank
you yeah and that's uh now my turn um
nothing really extra to add and um I
don't think we need to put a condition
on for that door thing that might be
something that the applicant might like
to do anyway um but that's up I feel
that's up to them so we've been round uh
once so if anybody wants to propose and
uh second if you want to put your hands
up because I don't think there's
anything more to be
said
do I have a proposer in the second so
councelor War booys I think you were
first and then councelor Humphrey
councelor War booys
please councilor War
boys sorry uh yes I'm happy to propose
that we accept this application thank
you very much indeed councelor humph I'm
chair happy to Second thank you yeah and
I don't think we need to read through
that the whole lot because it really is
pretty uh pretty well tied up for um
conditions on there so can we go to the
vote please oh wait a minute does
anybody want to speak to the motion
sorry beg your
pardon no in which case we can go to the
vote if we may please thank you chair so
if you could please respond with for
against or abstain councelor James
carsten
po councel Peter gold
cancel
gold he's
muted I'll come back to councelor
goldair at the end um so counselor gusri
four counc humre four
councelor
melon
four councelor Norris four councelor
Stringer four counselor War boys four
and counselor
gold
four did you get it yes thank you
counselor there we are so that is by Mr
depra if you could confirm I make that a
unanimous vote in favor of the
application that is indeed unanimous in
favor thank you thank you chair well
well thank you very much to everybody uh
for attending the meeting today and uh
particularly to Barry for chairing the
middle application site inspections uh
do we have any site inspection requests
which need to be reported to committee
no chair none
requested in that case then I now
formally close the meeting and thank
everybody indeed thank you very
much
bye